foreign
we could start there there's a uh chair
and vice chair meeting going on and also
so that's why the chair is not here him
and I are going to be switching off
uh so we'll start with the Bureau of uh
services
oh you just slide them all down
thank you for the opportunity I'd like
to have it here today to introduce
ourselves to you
um and a company me today is Matthew K
um I have had the honor and serving in
this role for the Bureau of Child
Support Services for uh over a year now
right I come into this role with
I have had the privilege and opportunity
to work for the division of Children
prior to uh joining the Bureau of Child
um so um and throughout my career here
at the child support program I helped a
variety is different positions both in
our management at the end of our field
operations
um so the information that we have
prepared for you today is to really
provide you with a general overview of
the child support appropriate to to
really uh speak to who we are and what
I understand that our time here today is
limited
Club so my hope is to take just about 15
minutes of your time to provide you with
some information and certainly allow for
any questions that they make out of us
but really want to be able to leave you
with information as a resource to you
moving forward for this session and if
we can be of any help or support or
answering your questions certainly we
will be here in available tooth involved
our contact information in my business
I don't plan to go over every slide with
you but uh certainly the information
that I will share with you
so we should start I just wanted to
share a little bit about our organizing
Constructor the Bureau of Child Support
Services uh lies within the Department
of Human Services and please sit within
the division of economic intelligence
and our program is um
is responsible for administering the
title 14 program for the State of New
Hampshire which every state is required
from Child Support Program
consistent with the Social Security
and our program is the child support
program in general is one of the largest
income support and anti-poverty programs
for families and promoted
and our specific Child Support Program
provides State Funding Certificate in 11
Austin with our Administration we have
essential information unit as well as a
federal intergovernmental unit
thank you
um
so our
um it's really the mission of the Bureau
of Child Support Services to encourage
responsible parenting and Family
self-sufficiency and Child well-being
and we do this by providing our core
services to the our families and that's
with locating parents establishing
paternity or legal fatherhood modifying
enforcing child support obligations and
obtaining child and medical support for
children
so we really believe that it's the
responsibility of parents to financially
support their children and we aim to
provide quality service to helping
parents through challenging
circumstances
concerning child support
one of our primary roles is to help
families navigate child support which
can be at times complex and so we find
our a lot of our work around educating
our parents and our families and trying
to connect them with the correct means
of services within the community and in
to be able to provide the best outcomes
so as I mentioned that you know the
child support every state is required by
our federal government to have a child
support program and to implement a state
plan to provide those services and
really the child support program was
created to ensure that children and
single parent family households received
a reliable source of Private Financial
and medical support
the child support program really serves
you know all families from all
socioeconomic backgrounds and in our
federal fiscal year of 2021 here in New
Hampshire our child support program
served about 33
650 Children and Families
so our federal office of Child Support
Administration really oversees the child
support program and provides a
tremendous amount of support to our
states
to help us develop manage and operate
our program according to our federal
laws
um and the child support program has
really evolved over the years to become
more flexible more efficient more
modernized and our federal government
has issued rulings to help
support the states in being able to
provide that flexibility to families
you know families have um interest have
differences in structures and supports
and needs and so the child support
programs recognize the need to be able
to be flexible and to modernize and to
keep up with the changes and the
challenges that families are facing
today so
um you know in New Hampshire
um our child support program is
um working to be able to fulfill those
needs for our families here and
um just to note that you know our
program is um
we collect and distribute private and
not government funds to families so to
help them pay and support their children
and meet the basic needs
um
we our services are provided to families
whose parents or caretakers don't reside
in the household and so we spend time
trying to ensure that families are aware
of the importance of um you know
positive co-parenting working together
as a family for the benefit and the
well-being of the children
there are part of our role is to ensure
that those parents who are unwilling to
pay child support who are obligated to
do so
um
that we work to try to compel them to
pay and provide that support we
certainly have a number of tools
available to us to assist the program
um in doing so and sometimes there are
circumstances where parents are willing
but unable to and so there may be a
barrier that is
um interfering with their ability to pay
so the program really focuses on trying
to identify what those barriers are to
help reduce those and provide any
um services or referrals to area
agencies or local services within the
communities to help families reduce some
of those barriers so the program is
really uh has to be pretty equipped with
understanding what services are
available to families to help them to
overcome some of those challenges
um certainly you know we do run into
circumstances where parents are just
unwilling but are able and in those
circumstances we do have enforcement
authorities that assist us in being able
to compel them to comply with their
child support order
so the child support program also
services and helps to reduce families
needs to rely on or need Public
Assistance whenever possible certainly
in circumstances where families are in
need of a temporary Public Assistance
through any of our benefit programs that
you know child support is a requirement
of their eligibility and so we will work
with them and assist them with obtaining
child support orders and assisting to
offset some of the costs that the state
may incur as a result of that through
their child support orders
you know in uh I think it's important to
also note and sometimes that
um in in order for an individual to
receive our services through um the
Bureau of child support that they do in
fact have to apply for our services so
even with a court ordered obligation
that may be payable through the Bureau
of Child Support Services our program
does require an application process and
we are doing we have uh opportunities
for folks to access information and
resources that are available to them out
on our website to help guide them in
accessing the services that we might be
able to provide we do also provide
services
to parents that live across state
borders in tribal communities and
internationally so we're not
um
uh so we we try to provide services on a
global basis
so I would like to just um highlight
um a little bit of some of the again
some of the core functions that the
program
um provides one of the programs one of
the services we offers is we locate
parents so parents who are outside of
the single family household if they need
assistance we can use a variety of
systems that we interface with to try to
locate parents so that they can become
involved in their child's life and or we
can work to establish uh paternity or
legal fatherhood in circumstances where
that may be needed and that is again one
of the poor services that we provide we
also work with our
our families to establish the child
support orders and medical support
orders here in New Hampshire all of that
is done in collaboration with our New
Hampshire Circuit Family Division
the since uh here in New Hampshire we
use a judicial process the port is
really a a good collaborator with the
bureau and we work very closely with our
court partners
and as I mentioned we enforce child
support and medical support orders
um and it you know again it's really the
responsibility of the parent that's
obligated to pay to be able to comply
with that and we really see that it's
our role and responsibility when we're
working with families to ensure that
they uh have uh the means to be able to
do so and if they are unable to do so
then we can act on some of the
enforcement authorities that we have
available to us
um such as you know a recreational
professional license revocation
liens on income withholding order for
wage garnishments and payments and if
needed and necessary we can certainly
utilize the court to assist us in
ensuring that an oblivore or a person
responsible to pay support
is able to do so through those means
I think what's important to note here is
that the bureau really tries to take a
progressive approach to engaging our um
obligor or obligated population to pay
we really try to engage with our
customers to comply and as I mentioned
previously to really be able to identify
what those barriers might be and make
sure they have the resources to access
those um
to access them to be able to alleviate
those barriers so they can be in
compliance and provide them with the
choices that they need to be able to be
successful for the benefit of their
children
and of course our program collects and
disperses child support payments we have
a sophisticated
um child support system automated system
that interfaces with a variety of
of um different state and federal
um
um partners that allows us to be able to
collect and distribute and keep accurate
records of our
payments for the our families
and here in New Hampshire as in many in
all states we have a state disbursement
unit where all those payments are
collected and um dispersed from
and we have a provision in place where
all payments are required to be
distributed and dispersed within 48
hours to our families
in addition to the court being a um a
stakeholder that um The Bureau works
with certainly our employer Community is
also a big stakeholder for the Bureau of
Child Support Services where we want to
work really closely with our employers
here in New Hampshire specifically in
our last Federal fiscal year of 2021 71
percent of our collections that we
collect are from income withholding
orders so it's really important that our
program continue to work closely with
our employer community
and we also of course as I mentioned
um collaborate with many other state
department agencies as well as other
non-governmental agencies as well to
um
you know the child support program as I
mentioned has been transforming and
we're really promoting a real
family-centered approach to strengthen
parents abilities to become more
self-sufficient and to be able to
support and care for their children try
to reduce any stressors that may be
impacting but really you know at the
core in the heart of it our role is to
really ensure that the child and medical
support obligations that are ordered
here in New Hampshire are being
fulfilled and are being
provided to to the children and families
we do work with a number of Outreach
groups and
individuals to help promote the services
that we offer because we recognize that
families are in
have a number of challenges in raising
children today so we really want to be
able to provide assistance to both
families both both parents excuse me and
really assist them through navigating
the child support process wherever we
can so we have a very dedicated and
confident and professional Workforce and
you know really as I mentioned just here
to be a a resource to all of you and to
the families that we serve and we want
to be able to you know help our
community understand
whatever we can to assist them in
educating them in relation to the child
support program as that also extends an
offer to all of you so understanding
that our time is limited that is just a
basic overview and a general overview of
the child Support Program certainly
attorney Hayes and I are available to
answer any questions that the committee
thank you very much are there any
questions
representative McMahon thank you Mr
chairman
uh if I just clarification on appreciate
the data you provided when it says 71
percent from the parents check one of
the parents is that first a court order
before garnishment can be implied or
done
that is so the 71 percent uh collections
of income wage garnishment
um
thank you for your question
um is in relation to our total number of
collections through the federal fiscal
year of 2021 any any orders that we were
collecting on and or enforcing on work
collected by an income withholding order
which is uh part of our child support
orders here in New Hampshire
and and follow-up two things that is
just your guidance both of you on the
the timeline once there's an application
to the court and how long does it take
to facilitate it when you have a need
like tomorrow you know for the for the
the family but also is um
when it's 29 from other sources
what are the other sources to make up
thank you for your questions
um and if I understand what your
questions are so the um the first
question is the timeline from when our
program receives an order for child
support services to enforce from an
income uh and try to implement an income
withholding order if one is available
again I think it depends upon the timing
we try to
um we try to
uh in by way of practice enter orders as
quickly as possible onto the system it
could be up to a couple of weeks before
our staff can process those orders and
get them up once we're able to issue an
income with folding order it's up to the
employer to be able to process that
income withholding order what we try to
tell our families is to be patient with
their employer and that it could
potentially take up to four weeks before
they could get that income withholding
order set up on their payroll if they
have or if they're working with a
payroll provider but we certainly
encourage our paying parents to reach
out to their employer to inform them
that income withholding order may be
forthcoming and then our program will
follow up within a 30-day time frame to
see if you know if payments haven't been
received so we'll try to monitor to make
sure that payments are received Timely
and to answer your second question in
relation to what the other sources of so
that might be sources from unemployment
that may be sources from self uh payors
it may be sources of employment from any
liens or
um or Lottery intercepts it may also
include payments from our federal offset
program
thank you you're welcome
any further questions representative
Bickford
Cameron
um
chocolate study is possible Human
Services required to do a child support
study every four years
um can you get us
the last one or do you know when the
last one was
thank you representative Bickford Yes
actually our program just completed a
review of the child support guidelines
in just of this past month that is
published and is currently out on our
website but I would be happy to
provide a copy of that to the committee
follow up
um Not only would I like to see that I
would like to see the last time the
legislator led a study committee was
done
we used to do it legislatively and then
we allowed Human Service to do it on
their own if the legislative
one didn't get done
um
and then just one other follow-up on
page
give you a chance to write
um on your
Pages uh with the
after page eight so I guess with page
nine
this shows
near the bottom there that New Hampshire
spends a dollar
for every 3.15 collected and yet you go
to the next page it shows nationally
one dollar spent and they collect five
dollars twenty seven cents so it's like
wow that's kind of a wise disparity why
does it cost so much in New Hampshire to
um thank you for your questions
um so the cost of um the
for every dollar that is spent on the
child support program the child support
program here in New Hampshire based on
our cost Effectiveness ratio collects
three dollars and fifteen cents
and then nationally for federal fiscal
year as you correctly noted was for
every dollar spent on the national
program
um throughout
um that's five dollars and 27 cents
which is certainly
um
a there is a Formula behind the cost
Effectiveness ratio here in New
Hampshire
that I could
certainly provide more information to
you on if that's something that the
committee would like
to do it just looks like we're not doing
that well compared to the rest of the
nation so I'll leave you with that and
if you can give me any information I I'd
appreciate it thank you thank you
any further questions uh representative
Raymond
uh thank you chairman and thank you so
much for coming this morning I'm curious
about
um timing of the collecting of child
support child support payments and the
distribution of those payments to the
other parent so
um we've been talking in this committee
about
um the potential of having a date like
on the first or the 15th of the month
that child support payments would be
collected and then dispersed how does
that work now is there like does
everyone getting child support payments
get them on the first of the month or is
it dependent upon the employer the
whoever is employed when they get paid
or is there some other mechanism by
which the payments are dispersed on a
you know regular basis as soon as the
payment is received thank you for your
question as soon as the payment is
received we disperse those payments out
to the other um to the parent receiving
it within 48 hours
okay so it all depends on when the
payments are received by the program
okay thank you yes
further questions I have I have a couple
um you you mentioned uh child support in
medical
okay so my first question is your um
you receive payments
from those that are just garnished I
know there are some parents that are
paying directly to their spouses to pay
is your payments are just by garnish or
do some parents send a check into you
other than an employee
thank you for the question
um yes we received payments from so we
receive and collect payments from
individuals who apply for our services
in the first instance not all families
apply for our services so the ones that
the families that do we collect and
receive payments in all sorts of of
manners either through income
withholding they can pay by check they
can pay through money order through
MoneyGram we through our contracted
State Disbursement Unit we have a an
option for electronic fund transfers so
that they can do direct
payments through their banking
institution there are multiple ways that
families can pay for their support not
just by an income withholding order
although that is the preferred and uh
ordered way if it is available great and
uh my other question is with respect to
Medical is it just
those that are in your system
it's it's those that are both child
support and you also
yeah so so it's not if I if I'm not
required to pay child support but as a
medical would you be involved in that
medical or is it just because of the
child support
thank you for your question
representative Wong and if I could just
clarify so in the state of New Hampshire
we have our uniform support order
process requires that both a child
support a financial obligation if it's
applicable and a medical support
provision of parents responsibility to
provide Health Care coverage to their
dependent if the agency if the bureau is
collecting and enforcing on that child
support order because a family has
applied for our services we will look to
enforce both child support and Health
Care coverage provisions
Health Care coverage in New Hampshire
can be provided in a multiple of ways it
can be through satisfied through public
health insurance through for example
Medicaid and or through Private health
insurance so if we have a obligated
parent who is required to provide health
insurance to their dependent and let's
say perhaps their employer provides
health insurance as a option for
employment and that health insurance is
covered under the amount that the
person responsible to pay is a
reasonable cost here in New Hampshire
then we will work to the employer to get
that dependent rolled enrolled in that
Health Care coverage so we try to ensure
that both the child support and the
health care coverage are covered great
hi thanks for coming sorry I missed your
presentation I was in another meeting
um I have a question somebody recently
asked me
when you have a situation does child
support always end at 18 and the
situation that someone came to me when
you have a child that become you gained
guardianship of because of a disability
after 18 where does that are there any
child support
like the medical after 18 if you have
guardianship or if there's a adult child
so like meaning you have lifelong care
of that dependent
there's a divorce does it end at 18 I
guess
somebody just recently reached out about
two dependents that that's the situation
thank you representative for that
question
um I I think that there's kind of two
parts in your question there and I don't
know that I would be um ultimately
informed to be able to answer that
question for you properly because what
I'm hearing you ask about is
um does
does uh child support end at 18 or the
provision for health insurance coverage
in a child support end at 18 and then
there's a second half of that which it
sounds like continuing Health Care
coverage after somebody turns 18. again
the the piece that I could really speak
to is that you know the uh the we
enforce orders
both health insurance and child support
through high school graduation or age 18
whichever comes last and uh unless the
court order specifically States
differently so I would not to be able to
answer your second question I would need
to reach out to some of my colleagues in
the department to better answer that
thank you
any further questions
see you none thank you very much thank
you
so uh I believe the behavioral health is
Miss Ross
awesome
sorry about that good morning
um for the record I'm Rebecca Ross the
director of The Bureau for children's
Behavioral Health which is within the
division of Behavioral Health that
Health and Human Services
um I see a bunch of familiar faces and a
whole bunch of new ones so I have tried
to put together a presentation that
gives some background current state and
next steps I will try my best not to use
um acronyms or nicknames in a way that I
lose people quickly I do get excited
about what we do and talking about it so
please stop me if um if I slip one in
and you'd like an explanation I have
tried to leave them out of them you get
a gimme on DHHS
oh boy I could be here a long time
um thank you representative Pearson but
please do stop me
um because we have been moving fast over
the last few years
um does everyone have the presentations
now okay great
so
um I believe I have a half an hour I
will try to do my best to to stay on
that
um
the first slide after the cover page
is
um just a representation of our org
chart showing that our division is under
the same associate commissioner as the
division for children youth and families
and until very recently we really didn't
have
um
a distinct Bureau for children's
Behavioral Health there was a lack of
access across the board and particularly
for high intensity voluntary Services
which could only be accessed in dcyf
cases through a court order
so
um when we were created we were put
within the division of Behavioral Health
Services but under the same leadership
as dcyf so we continue to work closely
with dcyf to serve their population as
well as individuals that are not court
involved that need access to treatment
going on to the second slide I work in
the Bureau for children's Behavioral
Health we're broken up into three units
our system of care which many of you
have seen and heard about over the last
few years is made up of five tiers
our Bureau is broken up into three
bureaus and one two and five are within
the system of care administration we
also have intensive
community-based services and the third
Bureau is the residential treatment
services and so
um we'll explain what those tiers are
and what's included in them in the next
few slides but that's how we've
organized the work that we have and we
have a total of nine people
supporting the work throughout the state
and really
driving the work that started in 2016
with the first
statutory reference to a children's
system of care the community and state
work started a little bit before that
but in the 2016 session
the first version of RSA 135 F was
adopted which is the children's system
of care law it charges both the
Department of Education and the
Department of Health and Human Services
with creating an integrated system of
care
and you'll see that it's developed
they've developed a comprehensive plan
for improving Effectiveness efficiency
and integration of children's Behavioral
Health Services and we take that mandate
extremely seriously that in everything
we build we're trying to eliminate those
silos figure out how people are going to
access them how people are going to know
about them and how they are going to
work together to serve the children
youth with their families
in 2019
um the Senate bill 14 was adopted and it
not only amended RSA 135f but RSA 170g
which is Children's Services which
historically was only dcyf services
this law change expanded it to really be
encompassing of all children accessing
Behavioral Health Services so we
continue to certify those providers
under that statute but they're not
exclusively for dcyf involved families
um Additionally the public assistance
statute was amended to include the
mandates to create a benefit for our
High Fidelity wrap around through a
Medicaid State Plan Amendment and create
mobile crisis Statewide for children
and we have Incorporated that into
Statewide rapid response and we'll talk
a little bit more about that but that
was one of the major drivers when we
built the rapid response system
the statutory framework includes the
values for the system which are that
services our family and youth driven
Community Based culturally and
linguistically competent and
trauma-informed was added in 2019. and
we incorporate that into everything we
do it's incorporated as a requirement in
all of the contracts with providers
consultants and other individuals that
we work with to ensure that we have that
consistency and integration across every
tier and every type of service that is
um so what does a system of care include
going back to 135 F it's not just
children's Behavioral Health it's not
just dcyf involved youth but it's
children with disabilities the special
education statute
um Services under 135c which is the
traditional mental health statute
early intervention including our child
development Bureau for example
and the child care scholarship program
in early supports and services so
essentially anywhere starting from that
very early assessment and contact with
families the services that we are
supporting for families
should be consistent with those system
of care values and built and improved in
an integrated way
the framework requires us to have a
uniform or Universal assessment in those
contracts we've selected the cans so
that is the child in adolescent needs
and strengths tool historically it was
done at the community mental health
centers which are a tier 2 service
and we have included it in our
residential programming our contract
with the operators of Hampstead Hospital
the dcyf child protection protection
workers and juvenile probation and
parole officers have been trained so now
we have information on strengths and
needs of children throughout the system
that we can look at how they are
improving or not as well as how
providers are performing over time it's
going to be a lot of work to refine
those Data Systems to make sure that
we're best using that information which
is a goal of ours but for the first time
we can really start to look at
measurable data on on how we're doing
and how healthy our children and
families are
so I will use cat cans going forward
um but uh I've defined it and I think
that it'll make sense in the future
context but that's becoming a very
Universal
term for our system including as
individuals are looking for what level
of care asking what did the cat what did
the cans identify what are their
strengths what are their needs how can
we
um you know lean on their strengths and
what do we do need to do to meet their
needs and all of our providers are
starting to talk in that same language
there are some additional drivers of the
system of care work that we're doing
Beyond just the
system of care laws in New Hampshire we
also have the 10-year mental health plan
which in 2019 it was the first plan that
included Children and Youth
um the Juvenile Justice transformation
work that requires an assessment which
is a modified version of the cans prior
to law enforcement or prosecutors filing
a petition for delinquency in court to
determine whether or not community
supports are more appropriate and
available and connect youth before
they're ever court involved because we
know that once they are court involved
it is much harder to step back from that
court system and if we can get them
before that
we have a much better success of Never
Getting to court or staying court
um I have
included a little bit more of an
explanation of those as well as the
family first Prevention Services act
which is the federal act that was
adopted in 2018 that really changed the
way title IV foster care funds follow
the services supporting prevention for
the first time and putting some guard
rails on the use of residential
placements to require them to be
treatment could I ask you to call out
either the slide number which is in four
point type or better the page number in
the lower right hand corner because I I
fear we're on different pages okay yes I
am on the bottom of page five and when I
realized that my presentation was so
long I chose not to do full-size slides
I am happy to email them because you can
see it a lot better if particularly the
data and not just the slide numbers so I
will I will stick with page numbers to
to help guide us
um so we've also come up with a new
graphic to really show the big picture
so so at the top of page six and you
cannot read all the tiny little things
in the blue boxes but we will be
explaining and walking through those and
I'll get to the electronic version but
essentially we've created a graphic that
is a circle with child and family in the
center
and
um the five tiers wrapped around
with rapid response on the outside of
all of that because it can support any
level of care these are not rigid tears
people will move in and out of systems
some providers will primarily fit in one
bucket but maybe surveying kids in in
multiple tiers it's more of a framework
and a concept of how we start and move
through the system supporting children
and families so starting at the lowest
level including
every child and youth with assessment
screening and treatment moving on to
community-based Services which would
include outpatient counseling Community
Mental Health Centers to the Intensive
Care Management Services tier four our
residential system and tier V are acute
system so originally when we looked at
this it was the acute psychiatric care
hospitalization but we recognize that we
need to ensure that the emergency
departments as well as rapid response
are really included in one one tier
and so because rapid response can serve
at any any stage or any phase of a
crisis including up to tier five we've
included it in tier five for discussion
and we know that the emergency
departments in our hospitals are doing a
lot of work to stabilize and support
children and family as they move between
the necessary services
so moving on to the bottom of page six
tier one that assessment screening and
treatment is intended to be the services
accessed by all children all children
are going to school or child care or
their pediatrician are we doing those
screenings and assessments and sending
them and referring to the appropriate
um
tier two looking at those
community-based services including our
federally qualified Health Centers some
dcyf specific services
but primarily Our Community Mental
Health Centers which prior to the system
of care were really the only place
besides private counseling or
hospitalization for children and
families to go if they were not involved
with dcyf
the bottom of page seven shows some of
the
increase or overall growth in the
community mental health centers so the
bottom red line is that trend line over
the last few years
um for Youth and you can see that both
Youth and adults have seen a substantial
increase and we know that there are
still capacity issues in community-based
services but we also know that capacity
has been growing and it doesn't feel
like that for the children and families
who are on a waitlist who were who still
have needs and who can't get them met
immediately but we do also have the data
that supports that we are expanding
access for that population as well as
the adult population is just not keeping
up with the needs that have grown over
the last few years
the Intensive community-based Services
also driven from RSA 135f started out
with what was known as and still is
known as fast forward it's New
Hampshire's High Fidelity wrap around it
is an evidence-based practice
um and we have expanded greatly over the
last few years when we provide that
service as a Medicaid benefit through a
state plan Amendment we have to renew
that every five years the first time we
submitted it five years ago our
projection was that we would be
surveying approximately 150 families a
year we are well over
500 at this point combined with with our
truck services that we'll talk about but
well over 400 at any point in time which
was not anticipated and is a huge impact
on Staffing for the agencies that are
providing those services our peer
support agent agencies that are part of
that model
and essentially everyone else that's
connected to it serving those families
is a is a high intensity service with a
lot of contact
that takes takes a lot of the workforce
and we're very excited about the number
of families being served that means
they're not moving into residential or
sitting in our emergency departments or
being hospitalized but it does mean that
we need more and more Workforce every
day
so in addition to fast forward
we have added Trek was which is
Transitional residential enhanced care
coordination built on the same model
serving individuals in residential care
or psychiatric care including at sysc to
transition them safely back into the
community and then most recently we have
added the Early Childhood component
which is the zero to five population
and based on exposure to Aces as well as
a child's diagnosis so really supporting
the caregiver and looking at
um the environment the child is has been
exposed to to meet their needs before we
see them later on in their childhood and
Adolescence the Care Management entities
are
specifically
um we have two contracted entities in
New Hampshire they are conflict-free so
they are intended to be able to assess
and identify those needs and connect
families with those services without
referring to themselves and they are
looking at the goals of using the Care
Management entities are to improve the
clinical outcomes enhance efficiencies
and control costs and Foster resiliency
in the families and youth that we serve
and on the first five years and our
pilot the data has been very supportive
of those fast forward services and we're
starting to look at that data as we're
building into Trek and the zero to five
models
the components include the page number
please thank you
um page nine the top slide
so for all of the services there's some
form of enhanced care coordination
family and youth peer support obviously
the zero to five model is modified that
you know they're not receiving youth
peer support and the peer support is
focused on the caregiver
customizable goods and services and the
Care Management entities have
responsibilities through their contracts
to also help
develop that provider Network through
training through identifying the best
practices and collecting data on the
services used and the outcomes so they
really are Partners in continuing to
measure the system
and expanding the services because the
the Care Management entity and the care
coordination isn't the clinical service
and they're still engaging and
connecting them with those Clinical
Services so it's
essentially the navigation for the
family that has a number of different
needs that will be met through different
Community providers
the bottom of page nine shows the
history of the system of care
development starting with that original
pilot and Grant in 2012 and the most
recent Law changes in 2021 we have not
added the 2022 I think we're going to
have to move to two slides eventually
but this really does show how much has
changed and how many major Milestones
we've hit in just about 10 years
moving on to the top of page 10 is that
fast forward data and through our two
Care Management entities you can see
that
um it was really 20 fall of 2020 that
our second Care Management entity came
on board
um where those purple lines start at the
bottom
and between the two 130 and 360 we are
very close to that 500 number just with
those fast forward families
um
the transitional residential enhanced
care coordination
um on the bottom of page 10 is the same
model for youth that are within a
program or facility and that started in
July of 2021 and we at the end of
December of 22 we're serving 140
families the goal is to serve All
Families or all youth that are in
placement
as we build up Workforce we will
continue to see that number grow until
we start to see the number of Children
and Youth in residential going down
but right now to prioritize we are
serving children and families who are
um not in the dcif system that don't
otherwise have a caseworker assigned
that can help do that coordination so
the majority of these children and youth
are not dcyf involved with the exception
of the identified complex cases and the
youth at the sununity Services Center
who were prioritized to receive that
um and then the Early Childhood just
rolled out this summer we received money
about a year ago and
going to the the bottom of page 12
um at the end of the year we were
serving about 18 families and we know
that that is is going up and as we have
more coordinators trained for that
specific population that we've completed
or created specific training on top of
the New Hampshire wraparound model
training we will onboard more and more
families for that population
it is as I said earlier and it's on the
slide on the top of page 12
um eligibility can be based on exposure
to Aces and the caregiver needs not
exclusively the child's needs and that's
getting wrapped into our Medicaid State
plan to be effective next July 1.
right now it's supported with other
funds but we're continuing to grow and
hopefully as as that grows that Medicaid
benefit will come on board
tier four is the residential treatment
there's been major changes with
Residential Treatment including moving
to a Contracting model in the summer of
2021 adding a whole host of deliberate
deliverables including training data
incorporating the system of care values
where previously it was uh license and
certification system where those met the
minimum standards and that was the
extent of our oversight with the
exception of Investigations now we have
required contract Provisions that we can
monitor and oversee and require
additional data including use of the
cans so that we really can see how those
providers are meeting the needs of
Children and Youth additionally we have
broken the providers up into levels of
care one through five one being
independent living five being
psychiatric Residential Treatment
Facility the most intense the closest to
inpatient which is what we are standing
up at Hampstead Hospital later this
spring so previously
there was no access for voluntary
Residential Treatment you had to be
court involved to access those providers
we are now serving directly over 50
youth through their families they're
quite required to participate with the
Care Management entity
um in the development of the transition
plan home because the goal is to be
there for as little time as possible and
successfully transition back into the
community
we're going to have to stop fairly soon
but I would like to since Hampstead
Hospital I live in Hampstead and she
lives next door
if you would address the question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you so
much for taking my questions
um
how many beds do you anticipate needing
and are necessary at Hampstead Hospital
thank you for the question that's
extremely complex
um
and I don't have a quick answer for it
what I can tell you is we're looking
very carefully as the data is moving and
doing a much better job tracking that
data the psychiatric residential
treatment facility that will be added to
Hampstead will be 12 beds you are
I don't believe it has not been decided
unless something happened yesterday that
this will be cited in Hampstead I assume
it will be but that has not been decided
am I correct
I'm happy to clarify what I'm referring
to so currently there is
um plans and development of a
psychiatric residential treatment
facility which under federal law is the
psych under 21 benefit that is a
clinical service that's not the same as
the discussion regarding the sununu
Youth Services Center thank you I
apologize for that no problem so we've
been working on the prtf for a couple
years now
um and as soon as construction is
complete to bring the unit up to the the
needs for a different type of facility
that will be opening in the spring
that's the existing building in
Hampshire thank you it's just 12 beds
within the existing facility but we
don't have that level in New Hampshire
now so any youth that needs that level
of care is required to go out of state
so this is a huge step for us to start
to have those first 12 bets we hope that
those 12 beds will be all we need
because we can have much better
engagement
and that we can have a shorter length so
stay and ultimately that does meet our
needs we we just don't know that yet we
also know that there are specialty areas
such as dual diagnosis individuals and
others who who may still either need
out-of-state care or we may need
additional four or six bed specialty
units but we're going to start with
these 12 and and see where it goes
um so moving on to the top of page 14
our comprehensive assessment for
treatment that's how we figure out what
level of care and individual needs we
take the cans information and add family
and
interviews of other individuals in a
child's life including teachers and
coaches and other primary caring adults
as well as review of Prior documentation
to establish whether or not they need
Residential Care and what level if they
do and then we match that up with the
providers who we've changed to the
Contracting model on the next couple
slides you can see those levels spelled
out as well as the first year where our
assessor did 768 assessments from
October of 21 through September of 22.
also another area where for the first
time we actually have clinical data that
we can start to measure to assess system
needs and how many beds we need at each
level and shift our contracts and
programming to to respond to what we're
seeing we've never had this kind of data
in our residential system before because
we haven't had these Assessments in this
kind of tracking
so
um to wrap up we level five is that
rapid response and hospital care we have
on the bottom of page 16 in the first
year of services had amazing
um engagement with 25
000 callers from people in crisis 6 000
Community deployments including children
and adults and the biggest difference we
see between children and adults served
in the system is the rate of deployment
is much higher for children
um and that's consistent with the
national Trends Because by the time a
caregiver calls they've exhausted all of
the things that they are able to do in
that Home and Community and they really
are looking for someone to come out and
the system is based on as perceived by
the individuals and so if the caregiver
calls and says I just need someone to
come the system is intended to respond
to that and go and that happens a lot
more on the children's services so we're
doing a lot of work on system
Improvement and measuring and looking at
that data and partnering with our
universities
to to use that data in meaningful ways
and
um going forward
our biggest goal is to stay the course
on the amazing system that's been
designed and supported by the
legislature and Community stakeholders
ensure that we give it the time to grow
and develop and work as intended
knowing that when we started designing
and building this we did not anticipate
a pandemic and skyrocketing needs for
both caregivers and Children and Youth
but we do have the data to show that the
system is responding access has
increased and we still have a very long
way to go and I'm happy to send these
slides so they are bigger and you can
read all of it and take any questions do
you have a business card for each one of
us or contact to your office the last
page in this slide in set has
um a number of different emails and
contact information my email is the top
one but we also have direct emails for
inquiry to our Bureau in general which
is checked by multiple people not just
me so if it's a client question you
might send a family to the one that
three or four people check not just me
it they'll get back to them faster fast
forward cat referrals and then some
websites for our partners for the cat
assessment the Care Management entities
rapid response which is New Hampshire
988 and the community Behavioral Health
Association would you save me looking up
on the wonderful
two-pager that attorney John Williams
gave me your phone number so I can write
it right in here too please sure 271 of
course
5006 thank you you're welcome and we may
invite you back because we're overtime
now thank you so much for coming thank
you so much and all the questions I've
written down I will save for another
we're about to go into an executive
session and to review uh or maybe for
the first time in an executive session
uh we do not generally take testimony
from the audience you've had your
opportunity to do that both live and
through emails sent to us the chair at
his discretion has the opportunity if
needed to ask the build sponsor for a
clarification and it would be a
clarification on a specific point only
and not a re-hearing of the bill itself
this is the opportunity where we as a
committee
discuss it amongst ourselves and vote on
it
new rules with a very evenly divided
house is that the leadership
asks that the motion be made
is a positive one in other words the
motion is OTP I heard on that I forgot
that last time and allowed an itl motion
to be made first
OTP ought to pass and then seconded and
then we discuss it and that is the
motion we vote on in order for an OTP
motion to pass it has to have 50 percent
plus one a tie vote is a defeated motion
any questions on the process of
this
ready
okay
open the here open the executive session
on House Bill 31 an act relative to
raising the age of marriage to 18 and
would you like to make a motion
34 what did I say
it's already gotten three older
would you like to make a motion
I also uh I have an amendment to that
bill too you make the motion with the
amendment in one breath
I move that we
uh accept the amendment and move ought
to pass
ought to pass
number do we have it yeah we do yes I do
we do I have copies oh we will yes and
that was two breaths but that was a
figurative saying not literally one
brush
foreign
and it is seconded by representative
Grossman
Amendment coming around
and you can would you pass the amendment
we didn't get that
amendment number 49 uh
okay wow
make sure
does everyone have Amendment it says
double zero 49
and we can spend a minute to do a side
capable of Contracting or balanced
marriage
there's some paperwork that just came my
way
okay
yeah this is the agenda Fitz coming to
please take a look at the bill as
originally filed and the amendment just
handed out you will see on the amendment
0049h that there's a strikethrough and
that is the change that is made we I
recall there was a question raised about
the null and void so the sponsor has
representative Moulton
thank you Mr chairman
um I like the the strikethrough I I
think that there could be potentially
there is a there is a chance that there
could be a a marriage that's that's
already underway that that would be
more complicated if we just made it null
and void so I do I do approve of this
amendment where we just keep those ones
intact if there's any
marriages that are already
um you know consummated uh let them go
through a normal process if they're
going to dissolve those
um but from here on out just not
anyone else wish to say anything
representative Greg
sorry I have to ask a question first are
we only discussing the amendment are we
discussing ought to pass we are
discussing and thinking the amendment
okay okay
I don't have anything on that I was just
getting clarified okay fine thank you
anyone else with anything to share
Mr chairman
yes representative Nelson thank you for
taking my question I think people are a
little confused as to are we just
speaking about the strikethrough
specifically or the entire Amendment at
this time we are looking at the
amendment as it exists before you the
strikethrough says the amendment takes
we will discuss as amended then we will
vote on the amendment and then we will
vote if it passes the amendment we will
vote on the bill as amended
okay there's a
all right
um
I will be voting against the amendment
because first of all between the ages of
16 and 18
depending on who's doing the nose count
this three to five marriages that have
been done in the last few years that's
it it's not that a whole bunch of
um
eager 16 year olds are running off to
the town clerk to get married it is a
very very small number
secondly they are married only with
permission of the Court
and while I certainly do not believe in
the infallibility of Judges I do believe
that when two youngsters are presenting
themselves before the court to ask
permission to get married there's
probably a very good reason for it
also it has been stated in testimony
that it is impossible for these
marriages to be divorced because they
are underage and cannot initiate this
kind of a contract whereas the law as I
read it the other day seems to indicate
that such marriages can be dissolved
um so for these reasons plus the fact
um
I think the state is wise when it
interferes in the rights of individuals
unless it is absolutely a clear and
present need to do so I don't see the
Clear and Present need here and would
wish for the state to not be involved in
this age 13 yeah I can make a case for
that and I'm glad this was voted
recently but 16 to 18 I do not see that
so I'll be voting against it
anyone else yes representative Moulton
thank you Mr chairman um
I appreciate the
context
vote down on a 13 year old getting
married but we need to draw the line
somewhere and right now
um the line is at 16 and that is
immature and so it needs to be raised
and and this amendment would
keep in tax
the marriages that have already happened
and would just prevent any harm going
forward to minors to children that we
need to protect as Representatives that
are making the state law
so I still feel that
this spill is good as amended thank you
anyone else
thank you Mr chairman
um
you referenced good reason Mr chairman
am I allowed to
the question wondering who defines what
is good reason if two teenagers are
going before the court
um the court would do that and reference
my previous statement about
um I do not believe in the infallibility
of the Court believe me but every once
in a while somebody's got to decide and
um I also believe that between the ages
of 16 and 18
there should not be a marriage taking
place
um I'm a parent to three teenagers and
I just I can't
see how
you can make that kind of a decision
between the ages of 16 and 18 when your
brain is not even fully developed
so I support this amendment
representative Greg
thank you Mr chairman as somebody who's
and also being a committee that is you
know for the champion of children and
family I think we have to look at the
fact that we might only have five but
we're also sending a clear message if
you look at statistics 86 percent of
those under age between 16 and 18
getting married are girls young girls
they're not women yet you also have to
look at the fact that over 80 percent of
those males that are marrying the
females happen to be over 25 most likely
30 and stuff so then we then we run into
a situation where we have
um you know a grooming type thing or
abuse you also look at statistically
what happens because I you know I
listened to representative
um Edwards about what he said in his
descent he was the only descent in here
he talked about
um you know not wanting to give more
options as far as abortion goes so I you
know kind of delved into what are we
looking at when a 16 year old what are
the risks if they're pregnant versus
um uh single or married what's
interesting is the abortion rate really
doesn't change but what does change
dramatically is the fact of them not and
I'm I'm focusing on women because we
have 86 percent of the girls that are so
what changes dramatically is whether or
not they finish school once they're
married so between 16 and 18 the chance
of them not finishing school is over 50
percent
um the chance of them being in a
domestic violent relationship is high I
have worked in this this has been my
focus for years and also
um they cannot so if they are in an
abusive situation they actually cannot
go to a shelter for domestic violence
victims if they're under 18 without a
parent so I think those are all things
we need to really consider as far as
what's appropriate for the law we don't
even let somebody under 18 vote this is
a big deal
I question how you get 86 percent of
them are girls when the total number
is three to five sorry I'm talking about
a national statistic and I you know what
it is three to five but when you're
working on a um a massive epidemic like
domestic violence we're still and we're
working with you know trafficking is is
going up and up we have to look at the
fact that yes it might be three to five
but if your child was one of those three
to five it would be a much bigger
statistic my child
um
would have to have the permission of the
court for a reason
I don't think domestic violence would be
one of those reasons or I don't think
trafficking would be so I'm wondering
how this enters I'm going to call on
somebody else we may get back to others
representative Nelson
thank you Mr chairman
um I have a couple of points here and
one of the points is going back to what
you
um alluded to
regarding whether
um
whether a married person who is a minor
between the ages of 16 and 18 would be
allowed to seek legal help hire an
attorney go to a domestic violence
shelter and in this section 21b3 it
states that the certificate of marriage
shall provide evidence of a Minor's
emancipation and the definition of
emancipation
is
um
I had it right here the primary benefit
of emancipation is legal autonomy
regarding one's financial and personal
affairs
so I do believe that they would have
access legally to sign into a contract
with an attorney I did check with uh
um domestic violence um
program here in the state and I was told
that no one regardless of age would be
turned away
so I disagree with with that
um
I'm not sure if we're supposed I'm
supposed to disagree but I'm just
stating that I believe that what I was
the answer that I was given to be true
um and that's it thank you for your time
thank you representative long
thank you Mr chairman uh yeah it's not
complicated to me the fact that the
legal system has to
okay a marriage is the problem for me if
I had a daughter and she came up to me
and said uh
or this the gentleman came up to me and
said
is it okay if I marry your daughter I
wouldn't say let the courts decide that
okay so the fact that you're not 18
years old and you need to go to court to
get permission to get married is
problematic plain and simple thank you
okay uh don't repeat what you've already
said if you have new information say it
and briefly please representative
Moulton thank you Mr chairman to Circle
back to the domestic violence portion of
this
um I can tell you that domestic violence
abusers they will wait until the
relationship is secure in the form of a
marriage before they first strike in
multiple situations I can tell you that
from my personal experience that they
wait until they get married first and
then they become violent they're not
going to show their violent tendencies
when the relationship is still frail and
someone can break up easily
because they want
it's a it's a it's the mentality that
yes uh representative Bickford thank you
Mr chairman well based on that that's
why I just heard that's a great good
reason not to get married
ever going beyond that I two things um
one uh we do allow people 16 year olds
to go hunting and by themselves they can
have a rifle if they take a National
Rifle Association uh uh class uh we also
let them buy automobiles so we do allow
them to do uh dangerous things and uh
but I I do not understand the
strikethrough and how it why it's even
in the original one and if anybody
helped me with that that would
help me representatives of Eck would you
explain the strike through please in the
amendment uh so the strikethrough is
it's happened before I've had to amend
it before when I put the spell through
uh this would the strikethrough gets rid
of all marriages contracted by such
persons so being null and void uh what
it would do is just making sure that
those people that have gotten married
before this is enacted their marriages
are still intact but it's the
this bill would just make sure that
there is no further anybody under the
age of 18 getting married this just
prevents further marriages not ones that
are the humorous irony is they would be
grandfathered yes at such an age yeah
looks the opposite to me okay
thank you for taking my question Shannon
Pearson
usually if a child is getting married at
16 and I'm not saying that they're not a
little immature it's because the
the girl is pregnant and if you're not
going to allow
this consummation of marriage you're
forcing this situation
life and they don't believe in abortion
uh you're kind of putting them in a
situation to become more dependent on
the state
rather than letting the couple support
this welcoming gift
representative Raymond
um thank you thank you for um letting me
speak so I have
um three main points that I wanted to
make here
um the first is that um I approve of the
amendment the strikethrough
um I don't think that
um we have any business dissolving
marriages that have already occurred um
just as a as a as a point in general I
don't think that the state should be
interfering with legal contracts that
have already occurred
um the the second thing I would say is
that
um regarding having a child out of
wedlock it's 2023 more than half of
children are born out of wedlock these
days it's that's now normal and
children under the age of 18 are not
able to purchase their own health
insurance on the marketplace even if
they are emancipated which getting
married does but in those cases you are
not able to purchase your own health
insurance on the marketplace we also
have in-state law child labor laws that
prevent children ages 16 and 17 from
working full-time and thus being
eligible for health benefits through
their employer therefore the only option
for a child who is pregnant under the
age of 18 is to a beyond their parents
insurance which they are legally
required to provide until the child is
26 or B Medicaid that's it those are the
only options in the entire country of
the United States so an argument that we
should be allowing children to engage in
illegal contract with another person who
may or may not not also be a child
for the sake of a pregnancy
doesn't hold any legal weight here
there's no benefit in my opinion one of
the biggest
um
requirements and responsibilities of
this committee is to look at every
potential bill that comes across our
desks and view it through the lens of
what is in the best interest of the
child in this situation and so when I
look at this bill as I'm looking at
other bills that we are talking about
I'm asking myself what is in the best
interest of the child in this
circumstance be it a male or a female is
it in their best interest to enter into
a legally binding contract when they are
not allowed to enter into any other
legally binding contracts we have laws
against child labor we're saying that
they're not old enough or developed
enough or responsible enough to work
more than 30 hours a week therefore
we should continue that logic as a
society we have been moving towards the
idea as we develop that people do not
become adults until they have
finished high school and or turned 18.
that's consistent it's consistent in our
child support laws it's consistent in
our labor laws it's consistent in our
education laws and I don't see why
marriage as this random legal contract
that is intended for combining the
assets of two individuals would be an
exception to this rule so thank you
anyone who is not spoken the chair is
going to call the question which means
we vote on ending discussion I think
we've heard everything I'd like to see a
show of hands how many support the
calling of the question I.E we now
proceed to vote okay good now the motion
before us is the amendment that you have
before you with the strikethrough that
is what we are going to be voting on
the positive motion is to accept the
amendment if you accept the amendment
that doesn't mean you have to accept the
bill once it's amended you could do
whatever you want with the bill one
since amended this is simply to accept
the amendment if you accept the
amendment it's an I vote if you do not
accept the amendment it is a no vote
would the clerk please call the roll
Jim and Pearson no
representative long yes
representative DeSimone no
representative Bickford no
representative Nelson no
representative McMahon no
representative panic
no
representative Seidel
representative Grossman
yes
representative Levesque
representative Petrino votes yes
representative Perez is absent
representative Greg
yes
representative Moulton
seven to eight D the amendment is
if the amendment does not pass
the motion now before us is ought to
so set your Amendment aside we now have
the original bill with the strikeouts
back in
all marriage is contracted by such
persons shall be null and void the
motion
um
I think I don't have to do it but just
to be sure I will would you move OTP to
the bill please
I move out to pass
and do I have a second
so it's the same as before just to be
sure I think we didn't have to do it but
we made sure
that is the motion before us
moved by representative Levesque
seconded by representative Grossman if
you are in favor of the bill and the
motion ought to pass you will say yes if
not you would say no the clerk may call
the roll please
chairman Pearson no
representative long yes
yes representative DeSimone no
representative Bickford oh
representative Nelson no
representative McMahon no
representative ball
representative panic
now representative Seidel no
representative Grossman
yes
representative Levesque yes
representative Petrino votes es
representative Perez is absent
representative Greg yes
representative Moulton
yes representative Raymond yes
and we'll see you next year
will you do The Minority Report who will
do the majority report who is there
anybody who voted on the prevailing side
who would like to do it I'll be happy to
thank you
yes
representative Nelson said she would
want to be happy to Mr chairman oh
you're even happier than I'm happy thank
so you don't do itl anymore is that it
that's what we've been instructed to do
they want a positive motion even though
the majority of it may vote it down they
want a positive motion but when it goes
to calendar there's no igl like it used
to be
you should take a motion behind here
something
it's not going to be required it's going
to be OTP in the calendar
oh two
it makes sense let's do it we may not
need it but just to make sure let's do
it
I all right I will accept your motion on
itl then
I make the motion all right and a second
DeSimone
so we're just doing it Mirror Image I'm
not sure we have to do it but you've
been doing this a lot longer than I have
so
if we do we're doing it
I mean you wouldn't be ready the chair
will make your motion itl on House Bill
34 F and the motion now is itl moved by
representative Nelson seconded by
representative D Simone
and the clerk may call the roll please
if you are in favor of itl
say yes if you are not in favor of itl
say no everybody got that we had a redo
Jim Pearson yes
representative long no
representative DeSimone yes
representative bigfoid yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes
representative ball
representative panic
yes representative Seidel
representative Grossman
no representative Levesque no
representative Petrino votes no
representative Perez is absent
representative Greg no
representative Moulton no
representative Raymond no itl is eight
question I'm just curious if we did have
full attendance today and the vote would
have been eight to eight what would have
eight to eight is a no vote
no recommendation okay thank you
open the executive session on House Bill
200 choice of a counselor
um
to evaluate a child in Family Court
proceedings
and I will bring this forth on behalf of
Representative Nutter upman
how long have I known how if I've been
doing this as long as I've known you
up them Upham
representative
I move on to pass with the amendment
that is I think zero zero one o h
and it's coming around
it's coming it should be coming around
you I think so you've already had a copy
I think you're all set but there's
Mr chair yes is this amendment zero zero
one zero H yes it is thank you
we had discussed whether we needed to
have a different Amendment because we
were unsure about
um
insurance issues so the chair will call
the representative from Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs my dear
friend
Upham
thank you Mr chair
um
there were a couple questions that came
up last time and former representative
Mel Moran who runs several therapy
agencies answered
um quite well the question of insurance
because he said any child in New
Hampshire who doesn't have insurance his
their the companies will help them apply
for insurance because they're eligible
for insurance so I didn't feel that it
was needed to put it in the amendment
because it it already exists so the
people who would be directly involved
with the issue at hand say there is no
issue
no problem the problem we raised is not
a problem exactly okay thank you okay
was there one other question on here
it's only by way of a clarification
where there has not been okay
okay thank you welcome
this is true okay so representative
Pearson
um moves HB 200 with Amendment zero zero
one zero and
representative long second sit any
representative Raymond thank you um and
thank you for addressing the question
regarding
um the insurance comp uh coverage
um I just wanted to speak towards this
um bill I think that
um we had quite a bit of public
testimony
um and I've had constituents reach out
to me
um indicating that this bill would have
made a difference to them during their
custody proceedings and so for that
reason I am convinced that passing this
is the right thing to do
any further discussion
I
I hear
I'm sorry right here oh representative
Bickford I am
as you may know
um
uh bewilderment over the clause or in
the event that a finding of abuse has
been made and why that would disqualify
them from agreeing with
their uh former partner
may I call the prime sponsor back for a
clarification because you know my
liberal arts mind could read this three
different ways and it's a blessing but
it's often a curse so what does it mean
um thank you
um
the concern was and I spoke with
um Catherine Coco who is the head of New
Hampshire legal assistance
and she also ran it by Waypoint which is
the Children's Advocacy group in New in
New Hampshire and their concern was they
didn't want an abusive parent
overwhelming the other parent in
choosing a counselor so only in the case
of abuse one of the parents is abusive
it is likely that the the two parents
would not agree on a counselor and so
only in that instance would then the
court make the decision about who making
a fair and even decision about who the
counselor would be
follow up for representative you okay
okay okay and I think it would
discourage marital Wars over what
counselor that they were going to pick
thank you representative Nutter Upham
wow
the motion before us is how spill
the motion before us is amendment zero
zero one zero h
and I can I can take they tell me a show
of hands on this how many of you are in
okay it's unanimous and now we do have
to do a roll call on House Bill 200 as
amended by Amendment zero zero one zero
H moved by the chair and seconded by the
Vice chair and with the clerk please
this is a positive motion if you're in
favor you vote I
chairman Pearson
I'm sorry
oh sorry to give for us some experience
the assistant Clerk's maiden voyage
calling the role no pressure here
uh chairman Pearson yes
Vice chairman long yes
representative DeSimone yes
representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes
representative Mahone McMahon I'm sorry
sorry representative ball yes
representative panic
yes
representative Seidel yes
representative Grossman yes
representative Levesque yes
representative
petrigno yes representative Perez is out
representative gray yes
representative Moulton yes
representative Raymond yes
that's 15. yes the motion passes 15 to
zero Now assistant clerk what question
should you ask me
let's go
I have to go off though anybody what's
the next thing that should be asked
go on consent calendar
yes no objections it's on consent
wonderful it makes everyone happy gosh
do I get to write the blurb I guess I do
all rights
I've learned my lesson on that
now open the hearing on House Bill 471
this is the hearing on House Bill 471
and
471 471 do I hear
is that why representative yakella is
sitting there
representative yokala an alumnus of this
group yes thank you
thank you Mr chair and thank you members
of the committee
it it's uh
just trying to speed up the process
um as far as or encourage the judicial
system and the lawyers to speed up the
process and reach a conclusion in
divorce cases by
um
when a temporary order is given that the
court shall
schedule a final disposition hearing
and they would be able to reschedule
that for Just Cause
um but the uh there's a couple of things
that the
at the uh temporary order they have some
sense of the case and so they should be
able to know or have a better idea of of
how long the case is actually going to
need and so there is uh so that they
would be able to schedule it because
sometimes that a case may be an hour
long or multiple days long and so at
this um
temporary order they would have some
evidence of the complex complexity of
the case and then also
um
in uh hb124 from rep D Simone that you
guys heard on the 10th there is uh
not uh for for alimony temporary alimony
it is not counted towards your time for
uh
total duration of alimony
which is set right now to be half the
time of the the marriage the maximum
time so if you drag on uh having
temporary alimony for a year or two
years then that's really eating into
um it's it's not really making
um our limit of the temporary alimony or
the limit of alimony being half of the
marriage really
um
appropriate
um hopefully
um I don't I'm not sure if you guys
voted that one uh
uh hb124 uh odd to pass but hopefully
that will be another way of of
addressing
um kind of ongoing uh temporary
alimonies that just live in uh for you
know a year or more
um but the idea of this is just to have
something on the books so that everyone
knows kind of like we're shooting for
this date as far as ending this ending
this uh proceeding so that the courts
are not tied up as long and
um
and also just have everyone kind of on
the same page and shooting for the same
goal instead of just
issuing the order and then
uh it just be kind of out in the void
about whether or not when this divorce
is actually going to end like the
divorce proceeding is going to end
um and so that's kind of my my gist of
this this bill
um
and there was some suggestion of uh
um the judicial branch
uh using their scheduling conference
order
um and and
from from a constituent but I don't
believe that this the the scheduling
conference order
um it's kind of like a checklist of
things that they that they could order
and so I don't think it's appropriate it
to what I'm trying to do which is
actually get a final hearing scheduled
on the book so everyone's shooting for
that that date and so
hopefully you will be uh in favor of
this and voted off to pass I'm happy to
answer any questions
representative Bickford
thank you Mr chairman I'm not that
familiar with what happens now
um but I have heard people say it takes
a long time and is that what we're
trying to address here is the on and on
and on so if you can elaborate on that
please yes thank you for the question I
it is my understanding from the from the
testimony that I've heard before when I
was on this committee and then also from
uh from lawyers that they do see that
that cases are dragging unnecessarily
long and one of the reasons is that
there is no like set final date and so
they're just they're just making motions
whenever they they feel like it and
um not really trying to reach a
resolution by a specific date you know
the lawyers
if it drags on for a longer amount of
time they're going to get more money so
there's no real uh incentive for them to
call for a final hearing
um and so that's that's one of the
reasons why we're trying to kind of
incentivize the courts to say hey this
may not be the final day because they
could motion to say hey we need a longer
time frame you scheduled this for a
two-day hearing and it's going to be you
know four days or something like that so
we need to reschedule or you know
there's a legit reason that we need to
reschedule and it needs to be pushed out
further but
um
it's my opinion that they should kind of
have to prove that that's that's
necessary otherwise they should you know
try and resolve this within
um a reasonable amount of time thank you
thank you
representative Raymond
thank you so currently
um when people seeking divorce go to
court the court issues
um the temporary relief and then they
order the parties to mediation and they
have their court ordered time for
mediation you want them to also at that
time before mediation happens order a
basically a trial date for the
dispositional hearing
is that just so I'm understanding what
you're asked what the Bill's intention
is
I am not a hundred percent sure that
that is the
um normal flow like I think that they
could go to mediation before the the
temporary temporary order I don't I'm
not sure that that is
um
completely like the exact flow and
there's they're obviously uh Richard
head is here and he'll be able to answer
kind of like that flow as as far as that
and he's more of an expert on that thank
you
yes representative McMahon thank you Mr
chairman just one question sir sure do
you disagree with the methodology
description that's that states
when temporary orders are issued
that it's going to cost more money it's
at the there's not a due process time if
uh uh attendant should there be
conflicts and and espresso implied
agreement on what happens next if
something else comes up
I I know there's a class issue there as
well but it's where it's saying with
insufficiency inefficiencies in the
course schedule to then hear complaints
or disagreements in the be prior to the
um thank you for the question I think
you're talking about this the um the
sentence that says the branch states
that the bill may result in
um significant inefficiencies in the
court
um scheduled by booking hearings without
knowing time restraints or if hearings
are needed no if I may be it's the third
sentence less likely to know what issues
if any will be contested by the time of
the final hearing
uh doesn't due process then affected I
um thank you for the question uh
I don't believe so because if there was
an issue with that you needed to address
before the disposition you could then
just request uh the hearing be moved
under this under the the language of the
bill
um
the second sentence says the court May
reschedule the final disappearing for
just cause so that the lawyers could
just ask and say hey this I need you
know to have a hearing on this and it
needs to be heard before the
um the final disposition hearing and so
we need to push this final disposition
hearing out you know another three
months or whatever so so I do believe
that all of those issues
um would be able to be addressed
and and it wouldn't you know
uh
be contrary to either the person's
rights for what they can can have
hearings on or contrary to
like the best interest of of you know
Finding Justice
thank you okay
anyone else with a question
representative Greg
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here today and uh presenting this
so I just wonder if you know there's no
it says that they can reschedule with
just cause or whatever how does this tie
the courts if like the day before they
decide oh we can't do it tomorrow you
know the courts have this date reserved
and what that does with like costs
Effectiveness all that kind of stuff
like there's no
you need to like if we're going to say
okay you have to set this date there's
no like cancellation policy of like we
need to change it you know like thinking
in today's terms like what what does
that do as far as like I would think
that that could actually complicate it
and back up the court more because if we
have dates reserved and then we're not
using them you know too close to time
does that make sense
thank you for the question
um I believe that that you know just
cause like you got hit by a bus and
you're in the hospital and you can't
attend the hearing that seems like a
that could happen at any hearing for if
you know the day before
um and so I'm not sure that this would
necessarily be any different than any
other time and you would it would need
to be
um appropriate the judge would make a
call if it's not if it's because you
know you wouldn't weren't able to find a
babysitter but you had nine months
notice the the judge would probably be
like that's just too bad you're gonna
have to
um you know we're not rescheduling for
that that's not just cause
right so it would be up to the judge to
make that determination
thank you for the question
follow-up
um so I guess I it's not so much like
hit by a bus obviously we can't help
that kind of stuff it's more like so
there are certain times um let's just
say in contested divorces or whatever
where you're supposed to have Financial
disclosures but maybe if you already
have the state set sometimes Financial
disclosures come you know a month before
or whatever two weeks before you have a
grace period okay you have to get that
in there but the financial disclosures
aren't coming I mean divorce is never
really a happy thing so there's a lot of
times a lot of um you know kind of
conflict in one party or another not
giving what they need to give and so I
can see actually just cause being pretty
broad as far as okay well this party
didn't give this and so it I I
I guess I'm just wondering like um what
the provision would be like if there
would be any kind of like time frame
just so we're not hanging up our courts
and stuff I just that's my only thing
with that car accidents totally
different
thank you for the follow-up
um
I guess
um I'm not sure how the courts are are
tied up if they are not having the
hearing
if they know you know multiple
weeks in advance
because they're supposed to be you know
exchanging
um you know evidence multiple like weeks
in advance and and all of these
disclosures now
there's a bigger problem of of people
not actually exchanging those and no
enforcement mechanisms happening as far
as
as far as that and I do think that that
kind of goes back to the question about
whether or not you can actually
represent yourself or or defend yourself
or is is Justice being served if these
things are not actually happening
um
and so I'm more definitely more
concerned about that than
um
then scheduling out because I assume
that they're going to be scheduling out
of a decent amount of time like six or
eight months it's not going to be like
next week we're going to do the final
deposition hearing and so you'll have
plenty of time to know what
you know
what the final date is and be shooting
for that and trying to get things
resolved you know months in advance and
if you're not able to then you would be
requesting a continuance and say that
you know just cause we haven't been able
to resolve this we thought we were going
to be able to resolve
um you know my Bahama house and I and
we're not able to and so we're gonna
need to push it out another three months
or something like that I think that it
it would be rare that it would be in
such a short time frame before the
hearing that the court would essentially
be forced to be empty for that
um because
uh you know there's no there's no cases
to schedule in that time frame because
there was such short notice kind of a
thing I'm not sure that
um
how often that that would be the case
but obviously Richard head will be here
representative DeSimone
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
thank you question and welcome back
I just want to be clear that this bill
does in no way prevent anybody from
applying for
um
a continuance
at any time am I correct
thank you for the question yes this this
uh does not mandate that the courts
schedule a specific time frame it
doesn't say that
um you're not able to get a continuance
it's just trying to put something on the
book so that everyone is shooting for a
goal and not mandating that you have to
do it within six months or a year or
whatever you if if the courts you know
were able to schedule out five years in
advance they could schedule it out five
years with my and be in compliance with
my bill there's no
um it's just trying to have an end date
seeing no further questions
thank you for your testimony
representative thank you and
now we call on
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Richard head I'm
the government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch we do not support
this bill and and I just want to briefly
explain why that is
one of the sort of what I would describe
as the most important and valuable
resources the court system has is the
Court's docket that's the the place
where people's where everyone's hearing
is going to be scheduled and when a
hearing is scheduled someone else is
hearing cannot be scheduled obviously
um so you know to the extent somebody is
getting a hearing it means somebody else
is not getting a hearing it's just sort
of the inevitable process of blocking
off time on a docket
the other aspect of this bill is that
not we
one size does not fit all cases are
different
um and each case has its own sort of
issues and uh uh process and and
early on in a case we do not know what
all the issues are that are going to be
heard at the end of the case there is a
a process and a goal of the courts to
have the parties reach agreement and to
try to resolve issues and as issues get
resolved the the time necessary for a
final hearing which is essentially the
the final trial
hopefully become less less complex and
the the amount of time needed for the
hearing is reduced
so the question one question is early on
in the case how long do we schedule the
case for a final dispositional hearing
can take an hour it could take two days
it could take five days it really
depends on who are the witnesses what
are the issues what needs to be heard
and they're not sort of known early on
in the process
and and the other aspect of this is this
bill would trigger the Court's
obligation to schedule a hearing or the
final hearing
of some length of time whether it's an
hour two days five days
at the point of a of the issuance of a
temporary order and it's amending RSA
458 16. so I think it is important to
understand what is a temporary order and
when does it happen so a temporary order
under in a sort of a list in in RSA
and also says very specifically
temporary orders can be ex parte these
can happen very early in the process
essentially at the point of filing
directing any party to refrain from
abusing or interfering in any way with a
person or Liberty of the other party in
joining any party from entering the
premises enjoying any party from
contacting any other party and partially
reading these for time enjoining any
other party from harassing intimidating
or threatening
determining the temporary custody and
maintenance of minor children ordering
temporary allowance and joining a party
from transferring and cumbering
hypothecating concealing someone et
cetera property
those are the temporary orders that get
issued so some of these might even occur
before parties appeared we don't know
anything about the case we only know
that there's a an initial uh
filing there's a request for a temporary
order it may be export date maybe with
the parties exporting meaning the other
party is not there
um
we don't know anything about the case at
that point in terms of being able to
intelligently identify when how long
sort of who are the witnesses what's
going on in that in that final hearing
even if we got a little bit later into
the process there are a potentially in
in not all cases some cases can in fact
be be scheduled relatively early
um but you know types of issues that
judges see in in divorce cases you know
are there abuse and neglect issues when
you get into the financials is there a
business does there have to be a
business valuation
if somebody is self-employed is there a
self-employment valuation needed is
there a house at issue does the house
need to be appraised if there's a
guardian ad litem how extensive is the
guardian item's involvement going to be
in a final hearing what are the support
issues
income and expense calculations
sometimes require some iterations
asset valuation generally if they have
our IRAs Roth standards stock options
those need to be potentially evaluated
and valued during the course of the
discovery in these cases if there's an
underemployment issue somebody is
underemployed uh you know how do we how
is that information and evidence going
to be discovered and ultimately
presented to the court
are there child counseling issues does
the child do we need to get through a
process with a child or does there have
to be a temporary parenting order
in which the really the parties in the
court need to evaluate is that temporary
process ordered working in a way that
can be put into a final order
or the adjustments need to be made
because ultimately adjustments are
easier in a temporary order than coming
back after a final order is issued it is
it is there are a lot of moving Parts
it's complicated and what this bill
would propose is that in all cases
we have to schedule a final hearing at
the point of temporary uh at the point
of a temporary order
and just creates a significant burden on
the courts and and our ability to move
things quickly and we do think at the
end of the day this would create
potential delays because if we get a
motion to continue that trial
three weeks four weeks before you know
if we have two days set up for the for
for a trial here yes we can fill it with
stuff but it's not going to be somebody
else's final order because that's
already been scheduled because we
scheduled it a long time ago and also
parties are not necessarily going to be
ready on that day and time when they
already have another hearing scheduled
so it is it is
um
a potential where we are setting aside
time that ultimately does not get used
it's not being used as efficiently as as
it can so I don't think simply saying
that the parties have their Authority or
the ability to see continuances uh
really provides inefficiency and in fact
you'll hear from some judges that
motions to continue are really
discouraged because again we're talking
about a very valuable asset in the
Court's docket and once we've scheduled
something we want it to happen when it
occurs because it can be very difficult
to sort of backfill that space
especially if there's not that much time
available
so I think you know it does create some
um
if there is a specific issue as as was
discussed with regard to alimony you
know we didn't take a position on it if
there are if there are specific issues
that need to be addressed I think those
can be addressed on on your sort of
issue by issue basis but to sort of
mandate on all cases and all time in all
circumstances a final hearing be blocked
off on the Court's calendar that
blocking off creates
a a significant number of scheduling
problems what we do want to see is when
the parties know what the issues are
when those issues have been identified
by the parties and we've been hopefully
successful in narrowing those issues
which is our ultimate goal
um we can then set the the the final
trial date we know how long it's going
to take we know that we get a pretty
good idea who the Witnesses are going to
be
um and and ultimately the parties
um really do have a better sense of of
what they need to do and when they can
do it by
um and and that's how we do schedule
things
um with that
um I'll conclude my comments but I'd be
where are we good morning Tony head
thank you for being here sir uh
specifically to go and what you just
provided your guidance on
if um and and with this the statement in
the bill
stating upon the issuance of temporary
orders and then that timeline you
implied was to know what what are the
issues in dispute that's my word but in
dispute is that once that is known
uh would you
consider to facilitate an orderly
progression of resolution that a
timeline as set by the judge knowing
what the schedule is would be the final
disposition shall be on this date
and is that not an appropriate
incentivization of completing the
uh the proposal at hand so so thank you
for the question a couple issues one is
that as I mentioned at the time of
temporary orders which essentially can
be you know essentially shortly after
the filing of the right petition
there's not a lot of information but
once we are scheduling something for a
final hearing or final trial that's now
blocked off on our calendar and sort of
nobody else is touching that time
at the time of the temporary orders we
don't have information and enough
information to
to be able to establish how long do the
parties need for for Discovery how long
do the uh will the parties ultimately
need in terms of trial time
um and and it it really is not
appropriate at that early stage to be
able to set it what we do look for is we
have
um
we have at the the initial sort of
conference uh
parties are are with some exemption
exceptions
um
told to go into mediation we need to we
work on trying to resolve these issues
they're told to work with a court staff
person to try to to identify what
ultimately is at issue in in the trial
and then they come back after they've
had the opportunity to exchange the
documents to try to mediate to work with
court staff to reduce and identify the
issues then they'll come back to the
judge and uh at a at a pre-trial or a
scheduling conference when those things
are are resolved and identified and at
that point the trial is scheduled and
depending on the Court's docket whether
it be three four months from then or two
months you know it just depends on what
is available at that time
but there is a process we do try to
resolve these cases within a year if
there are no parenting issues they're
generally we're in we're at around 92
percent if there are parenting issues in
the low 80 percent uh in terms of being
able to to have these cases hit their
final hearing within a year doesn't mean
they all do it doesn't mean we can't
sort of do better what I think really
what is is Paramount is is getting some
more resources into the court so we have
more staff more judges available so then
we have more essentially docket times
available
in order to fill more cases into our
dockets
seeing no more questions thank you
attorney head and the chair calls rich
or Rick
Clark
rich
all right the chair recognizes me oh
wait a minute
and it's a Rockingham 32 Portsmouth
right
you may not only sit but engage your
microphone
so my name is Rich Clark I've practiced
law in uh in in Portsmouth and have
practiced family law in most courts in
and I'm here today because I have a lot
of clients friends family
that tell me the horror stories about
our New Hampshire family courts taking
years and years and they go on and on
and people are tired of it and we want
closure to our divorces and
that is why I'm here
so the the temporary order hearing
addresses two things IT addresses money
and custody
I can't think of much else that it
doesn't follow in but those are the two
when I meet my clients in that first
hour
no matter whether they have
multi-million dollar businesses or
whatever they're doing the size of their
estate doesn't matter I know in an hour
how to resolve the case
in in the last three years I think every
case I've resolved once the client comes
to me within three within 65 days of
meeting the client
so the complexity of the case to me
doesn't change by how much money
somebody has
those temporary orders
they sound temporary in nature but
they're not temporary those temporary
orders stay in effect until the divorce
is finalized
the court is well aware of what will
happen and they know the facts of the
case and how complex or simple it is
after the temporary order hearing
because custody issues and money is
addressed all of those things are
outlined
and quite often the court has already
tried these facts so they'll adopt the
temporary orders into their final
hearing
the time that it takes for New Hampshire
divorces
some of these
to go on and on for years it's
unreasonable
myself including other attorneys other
litigants have filed for scheduling
conference just to get a final hearing
date people want to get them done
I filed them six months after the
petition was filed the court will deny
it we're only asking for a final hearing
date because we want to get this past us
we want the damage to stop and we wanted
to move on
others have filed them one year after
their divorce was petitioned and the
court will deny just getting a final
hearing date
it's outrageous and these are the things
that need to change and I'll address the
money issues of saying this is going to
create a burden to our court I think
that's wrong
it's wrong because in the criminal court
system in New Hampshire
the court will automatically schedule
many things including the final hearing
date
yes most of these I think 98 of them are
put out and they're put out and the
clerk simply removes that final hearing
date
and someone else takes that spot
something else will always fill the spot
and to say this is going to be wasted
time I think that's wrong and I think we
can look to our Criminal Courts because
they automatically schedule those and
this bill simply requires
the court to schedule a date
the court can say this is a complex case
we're going to schedule out in a year
they could say it's this bill doesn't
limit the time they could say we're
going to schedule out in two years it's
just giving us a date of when we know
the final hearing notice there was there
was a question that one posed and that
was about deadlines and Discovery the
final hearing notice tells you what is
due when it's to be sent so we're aware
we are aware of the deadlines that's not
an issue
the continuance
of the hearing date
you know I had a I had a hearing once
and my mother died
and so I requested the court on an
emergency basis to continue it and the
court granted it
the court is very reasonable when it
comes to granting continuances but they
have to be for just cause it can be
a health reason whatever the reason is
for continuance it's not something that
should give you any concern because I
find that the courts are very reasonable
in how they deal with continuances
to address the issue of the cost to the
court
upon the temporary order hearing which
is typically heard within four months
and my guess is that they would schedule
the final hearing a year after so that's
a year and four months
so to address the cost issue
I can tell you from my experience that
the time
weight going between the temporary order
hearing and the final hearing there are
needless motions that are filed when
these motions are filed objections are
filed
and then responses are filed and I can't
tell you in a typical case how many
hours are wasted of the Court's time and
judicial resources because we don't
schedule a final hearing
if we simply simply schedule the final
hearing the cost to the court staff to
if there is needed more time for a
hearing a party can always request to
schedule that you can do a motion to
exceed time limits so you can request it
to be an hour and a half or two hours
I'm here to represent the general public
I'm not here to represent the New
Hampshire bar and what I can tell you is
that in my opinion if this were done in
these cases were expedited and a final
hearing was scheduled it would lower the
litigants attorneys fees that I'm
certain of when a case is done they
don't drag on and on and who it helps is
it helps the litigants so that they're
not charged because these cases
my clients have anxiety and stress when
they're going through their divorces
I'm still smoking cigarettes for my
divorce two years ago and I can tell you
that I went through a remarkable amount
of stress because my case alone went on
for years for years it's too long is
that reasonable I can tell you it wasn't
reasonable and I went through it and I
see others go through it and it's not
right
most importantly the damage is done to
our minor children
maybe you won't go through a divorce
but maybe your kids will
maybe your grandchildren will and who am
I here to support mostly it's the minor
children that go through a remarkable
amount of trauma when these cases go on
and on because they know their parents
are fighting they can sense it at home
and it's our courts that allow this to
go on and on for years
and what happens to the mental health of
our children when these cases go on and
on for years
clinical studies they show that they
become addicted to drugs and alcohol
crime is more prevalent
why do we need this to go on for years
we're asking for a simple cause here and
that's just to schedule it the court
could even schedule it 10 years out if
they want by the way this is written but
one in two marriages will end in divorce
two of mine have
so it happens to many people and the
probability of it happening to us or
to protect our children to limit the
injuries the injury that and the trauma
they will go through to help our
litigants just seek resolution and
finality at a reasonable time frame and
that's all we're asking thank you
attorney Clark would you take questions
representative Grossman
thank you Mr chair I'm just curious so
when you mentioned
people are getting denied requests for
that final hearing
are they given a reason
are there reasons for those denials
um to quote a few it says denied and
that's the reason and to me in those
cases that I was have been involved with
there's no cause to deny them other than
the court docket maybe I'm just assuming
they're busy or they don't want to deal
with it
but to file those a year after the
petition has been filed and for me to
hear stories of those that are denied
I just I that's why you can you can have
a good judge
that will make a good decision
I hail from one of the best family
courts in the state of New Hampshire and
that support Smith but we have a great
judge but if you trust the discretion of
those judges that aren't some of them
aren't competent in my opinion and this
we need to create law so that we just
get a final hearing because to deny them
a year after that's unreasonable a year
after the petition is filed
knowing that we're going to get typical
trial data year after that
so that's what I'm trying to hopefully
prevent
follow up
um and another question not related to
that one but
so are you finding that more emotions
are being filed
because that final hearing is not set so
instead they're going back to court to
try to make things but without question
and and those those filings and motions
and then objections and then responses
and hearings often take longer than the
thank you anyone else representative
Raymond
thank you Mr chairman and um thank you
attorney Clark for coming and speaking
to us today so I have to apologize my
experience is mostly with the dcyf end
of things so my experience in court has
been you you file a petition and then
there's
timelines like three months later you go
to court and then three months after
that you know you're going back to court
again and again until a tpr so
obviously divorce is very different from
that are there any trigger points that
bring uh where somebody involved in a
divorce would know the upcoming they're
going to be going back to court so that
there's not or is it just like a lag
like you get your temporary orders and
then you just kind of like wait and
Never Land until
something happens it's the neverland
okay absolutely
all right
thank you representative Bickford
thank you Mr chairman
um do you think this is because the
court is now overloaded do we have more
divorces going on now uh we don't have
marital masses anymore did those get
replaced is there a reason for this to
go on uh an attorney had said that
um um at this temporary level it's too
early it's too premature that's when I
get out of what he said and maybe
there's another point where it should as
I hear a trigger
um so those those are my questions if
you can help I've been practicing for 15
years and this has been happening that
long so the cases in New Hampshire
family courts drag on and on it's not a
recent problem this has been ongoing
it's been long term
and I think the complexity of the case
issue is a very weak one was
respectfully said this is just in my
opinion of practicing because
I can tell you in the first hour in
meeting the client what the issues are
how to resolve them and again it's
always two things how do we split your
assets in half typically and let's do a
parenting plan and the parenting plan
that New Hampshire has compared to
Massachusetts when I was practicing
family law there are very often is it's
nine pages
it's done very well a layperson can look
at the at the parenting plan that's half
of the divorce very simple very well
done you don't need an attorney for it
our issues in that temporary order
hearing they are fleshed out I already
know what they are in the first hour
meeting the client
always and that's why I resolved I think
every case I've done within 65 days of
meeting the client
completely because I already know in the
first hour what I'm going to do
and I can tell you if I know it I would
think that the courts do because they're
more intelligent than I am so they
should be able to flush these issues out
quicker
thank you we can hear about parenting
I see no more questions and I have no
more pink cards so thank you for coming
counselor thank you and I will close the
um
I'm hoping it opening hearing on uh
House Bill 438 FN and call Mr chairman
representative Pearson
thank you Mr chairman this bill simply
wants to ensure
that a youngster
is represented
with a friend companion when testifying
or being deposed
if you look at the bill you will see
that
there are Advocate employees who help
out
but that's not the same as having a
buddy there
we have come to learn the value of
having companion animals
they're very very important for numbers
of people
I think we can understand having a
companion person
when a child is scared because this
child has to give testimony
I'm in my 48th year of ordained Ministry
and on many occasions I've been present
in the back
of a courtroom
when a youngster had to give testimony
in some cases I was the companion person
that child wanted to be next to him or
her
and I can tell you
it's scary if you've ever been deposed
if you've ever given testimony it's a
scary thing
imagine how scary it is for a child to
have a friend next to you can alleviate
some of the fear
one question that one may
consider is what if the child picks a
bad egg and that person sitting next to
the child is signaling to others who are
giving testimony
the judge has discretion to throw
anybody out of court who's misbehaving
so in the very unlikely event I think
that there would be such a person
wrongly chosen to be the friend I think
the Judge could deal with that if the
judge saw this was taking place
so I encourage this committee to pass
this bill and I'll be happy to take
questions
are there any questions representative
disamoni
thank you Mr Vice chair and thank you Mr
chairman for taking my question
um you're talking about children in your
testimony and I don't see anywhere in
broaden it to anyone I did I because
this is children and family law I got on
that track in my mind I'm thinking they
may particularly need a companion but
you are quite right anyone could need a
companion so thank you for improving my
testimony
no thank you for helping me to
representative Raymond
uh thank you
um
will there be any
um restrictions on age of the individual
that the child or victim chooses as
their support person
and
would like a support or therapeutic
animal also be allowed under this bill
I don't see any age restriction on this
and I don't see the mention of an animal
one way or the other that would fall
under existing law where support animals
may be mandated under various federal
and state legislation
one quick follow-up
sure are you anticipating anticipating
any
um training or otherwise support for
this support individual so that they
understand what their role would be in
the courtroom
I wasn't but it sounds like a pretty
good idea that if you're going to come
to court to be that you should know how
to behave
um I managed to get to be age 73 before
I was deposed and you'd think I'd know
by now I've watched 21 years of Law and
but in point of fact I was given some
instruction before the deposition and I
would assume that anyone who came to
testify would be given instruction by
that person's lawyer
and I would assume a companion would as
chairman
um so my question is related to Children
versus adults I was a support person for
someone in their domestic violence
um
case
in which they asked the judge if I could
be there
um
initially
so for children
absolutely however do you think it could
potentially be contentious
for those that are adults even though I
believe it's a helpful thing to have in
the court system I just wouldn't want
this to become another contentious piece
in a in a situation where there's
domestic violence or control issues
of having that person bring someone to
court because it is this is applying to
again if it looks like somebody is
signaling whether they're from the back
or sitting past the bar
or causing A disruption
or clearly
is
um ganging up
I'm sure the judge would take care of
that because they already have when
there's disruptive people behind the bar
so I would assume that this would
continue
thank you representative Nelson
thank you Mr Vice chairman and thank you
Mr chairman for taking my question do we
have President
um in Criminal Court
um are there any people who are
um
campaign I'm sorry
the correct terminology it would be a
support person sorry about that
um it are there um support people aloud
in criminal court cases do you know I do
not know that but I know that attorney
had is turned in a pink card so he might
be able to address that thank you I was
a support person in a criminal case to
someone in one state an adult in another
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Richard head I'm
the government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch
I'm here to testify with some concerns
about the bill as written
um and I would be happy to work with the
chairman and the uh or the sponsor and
the and the committee if if changes are
appropriate
um the bill as written would allow any
party uh in any family court proceeding
on 173 B to be permitted a support
person and
um says explicitly such use of a support
person shall not be denied by the
presiding judge at least that language
is written I think has the potential to
create additional litigation and
additional conflict
um because Eve as the as the sponsor
suggested the court tries to control the
courtroom if there's disruptive behavior
if there is an attempt to try to guide a
witness in terms of their testimony
I think you're going to see that
language as as being used in
in an effort to retain the position of
um of of the support person I think the
issue of domestic violence and control
issues is a significant potential
problem and again the bill as written
says there so the judge has no
discretion essentially in allowing that
support person in if there are uh if
there's a there's a potential for
intimidation from the support person if
the support person is not truly there to
support but is there as a strategic move
by a party we would not as the as the
court necessarily be aware of that and
again we would not have discretion
um simply saying that a person person is
a support person I think would trigger
the statute we don't know anything about
that person we don't know the
relationship we don't know sort of how
it is they're there to sport why they're
there to support it simply says the
court you must allow it I think the the
potential for additional conflict
additional
problems additional disruption and
potential additional control issues is
significant in the way that this bill is
written one thing I I guess I would say
though is is to the extent they're
let me take a step back I think judges
in general if there is a request to have
a support person at the at Council table
or at proceeding
the court would at least listen to why
it is that that's appropriate and how
it's appropriate and how it would not
interfere with the proceedings what
um if there is a concern or if there's
experience by judges saying you know we
we can't allow you past the bar
essentially the rail
there would certainly be nothing wrong
with legislation that says the court in
its discretion
um may allow a support person to sit
with with the party you know once you
allow and in fact mandate touching you
can use touching as a way of signaling
testimony you can use that as a way of
signaling in a way that the judge may
not even recognize as happening because
it may not be visible I think there are
a lot of variables that that this bill
at least has written does not take into
account and and just creates a absolute
right of a party any party and an
absolute sort of prohibition against the
judge from from restricting that so all
that said I'd be happy to work with the
sponsor and the committee if if there is
additional language or if there's
another way of presenting this but I
think as written it creates such
significant barriers for the court to
control the courtroom the proceeding and
uh in the way in which the parties are
interacting that we would not support it
as written with that I conclude my
comments but be happy to take any
questions
in the first paragraph the preface
the finding just says it talks about the
uh what we call the coalition
uh
being there for people and
um so this is sort of looking back to
them and say Well they're doing it so
why can't we
and I'm not
sure to what extent they're allowed to
do that is someone have to be actually a
victim uh no not a victim but
um proven that they've been a victim or
do they make a claim that they are
um
so I guess I would leave it to the the
Coalition and the folks who were
involved in in sort of matching people
uh we would we would as a court upon the
filing of a of a domestic violence
petition give them resources
um to contact and try to have The
Advocates
um assigned but in terms of the details
I would leave it to the to the advocate
groups to describe that process
um sure no that's the answer I'm looking
for there's a it just takes a filing it
doesn't take a conviction or any finding
it's just a filing right a referral from
us is the filing what in terms of the
the process beyond that I would not
comment on it okay thank you
any further questions
see you none thank you Mr head thank you
very much I'll call uh
Lynn Charlotte
hi all right good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is Lynn
schillette and I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire Coalition
against Domestic and Sexual Violence the
Coalition is the umbrella Organization
for 12 community-based crisis centers
throughout the state of New Hampshire
that provide free and confidential
services to approximately fifteen
thousand victims of sexual assault
domestic violence and human trafficking
every year
I'm here to speak in opposition to House
Bill 438 but also to suggest an
alternate way that perhaps the sponsor's
goal with this bill could be achieved we
very much appreciate the intent of this
legislation in ensuring that victims
receive the support they need After
experiencing abuse however there are two
specific points we would like to address
the first relates to the introduction of
the bill should the committee move
forward with this bill we would ask that
you remove section one
which references nhca dsv Advocate
employees because it is not accurate the
Coalition does not employ any Advocates
who provide Direct Services to victims
those crisis center Advocates are hired
and trained and employed by the
individual community-based crisis
centers throughout the state and they
provide critical life-saving services to
victims including safety planning 24
hours a day around the year
to the point that was raised earlier
Advocates receive extensive training in
fact it's mandated by Statute that they
receive a 30-hour training course and
the content of that is very specifically
dictated in that way those Advocates are
able to help victims navigate the family
court process
the second concern I'd like to raise is
I don't think the statute is the right
place to address this issue there are
protocols in place which have been in
place for over 20 years in the state of
New Hampshire through the family and
District divisions of the Circuit Court
to be used in domestic violence cases
these protocols were developed with wide
input from a multi-disciplinary group of
professionals who are part of the court
process in family law cases
the protocols reflect best practices in
the courtroom and they're regularly
updated to ensure that they are in
compliance with both state and federal
law
moreover as the other Witnesses have
referenced these protocols were
intentionally designed with victim
safety in mind unfortunately as we know
one of the most dangerous times for
victims is when they seek to leave an
abusive relationship for that reason a
trained Advocate is able to provide
options and information and resources at
this very risky time
currently these protocols allow a victim
of domestic violence to have a trained
crisis center Advocate present with them
during a protective order hearing
however these Protocols are not in law
and therefore Advocates don't currently
have a statutory authority to attend a
hearing with a victim and I'd like to
share some specific language from the
protocol the protocol set section 7-7
provides that if the plaintiff is
accompanied by an advocate The Advocate
should be allowed at Council table and
may be allowed limited participation in
the proceedings at the request of the
plaintiff so some of the questions
you've been raising about the parameters
of the role of that person are already
defined in this protocol
and even when Advocates are present in
the courtroom the protocol has specific
limitations when it comes to the scope
of their role in working with the victim
as I mentioned previously these
Protocols are routinely updated and in
fact are undergoing a revision right now
so I would suggest to you that that
revisionary process would be the
appropriate place for a dialogue if the
scope of a support person for a victim
of domestic violence is going to change
there's already a document it's being
used by the courts Court Personnel
judges crisis centers throughout the
state
so in conclusion we would ask the
committee to vote itl on this bill we
agree with the Bill's sponsor that
victims should be allowed to have
critical support during protective order
hearings however that Authority is
granted by the court protocols and not
in state law so thank you very much I'm
I have one if I may
um
be satisfied with a Carvel for domestic
are you uh thank you for the question
representative anybody else could get a
support person except for a domestic
violence Victim Because that's already
been worked out with the court system is
what I'm hearing
it's I'd have to think through that a
little it strikes me that would be hard
to administer because this is talking
about family law cases but also sexual
assault victims have access to Advocates
and trafficking victims I think we'd
have to think through that it might be
might take a little longer to answer
that question okay thank you any further
questions representative Bickford thank
you Mr chairman
um again at what level
um does someone come in be called a
victim it can it be just on a claim
or it doesn't have to be a finding
before they get that kind of support
thank you for the question I'm actually
glad you brought it up again so there
are a variety of ways that people reach
crisis centers to seek support sometimes
someone who was raped or battered just
picks up the hotline or walks in the
front door as attorney had said
sometimes they show up at the courthouse
and the referral is made by the court
staff we also get referrals from a
variety of other professionals law
enforcement in particular but there's no
factual showing that has to be made for
someone to get help at a crisis center
they just have to come in and say I need
help
so uh I'm not talking about a question
I'm talking now about having someone in
court with them in the family court is
this bill is about well in this case
they would be a party in the family law
proceeding so yes the proceeding is
going on it has not concluded they're
not has not necessarily been a certain
finding but my reading of the language
is that
um that anyone in a family court
proceeding an adult or a child would
have the right to this if they wanted to
I'm talking about your organization
your the first paragraphs
okay it does not require a finding
before you get help from the Coalition
absolutely correct in fact the vast
majority of victims that we serve do not
engage in the criminal legal system or
the family system they're never in a
courtroom at all
thank you
further questions
see you none thank you thank you very
much representative I'll leave copies of
a call up to the honorable uh Betty Gray
Betty gay
foreign
thank you
um
in no particular order I will address
many issues that have been brought up
this is the second time to bring this
proposed Bill up
um so I've heard the arguments before
I was a little puzzled as to that they
thought this needed an FN
because I don't think it costs the court
anything to have someone stand with you
when you testify
other states that authorize a support
person
do clarify that that's what a support
person does they don't do anything else
they just stand there with them wherever
the person who asks for the support
request whether that's sitting where
they can see them or whether it's
standing right with them or whether it's
touching them
um one of the counselors in Salem had a
client who had been severely beaten by a
partner and she got brave enough to
testify and bring charges
but when she was faced face to face with
this person who had assaulted her so
seriously she was terrified so I think
we would say that was PTSD
in the courts by federal law
apart a victim of PTSD can have a dog
and we all know that that you don't just
go get a dog you know that has to be
prescribed and recognized that you
deserve to get a dog and then you have
to spend or get some people to help you
spend a lot of money to get a dog
so when a person is a victim of a crime
whether it's personal nature or whether
it's you know a stranger they can still
have the same PTSD and that doesn't mean
that they have time to recognize that
they need a dog
or they have the opportunity to get one
probably hoping that they won't need
this forever but court can come up
pretty quickly and we've done our best
to help victims be brave enough to press
charges
but when they get to court and suddenly
their their gut instinct is to be
scared to death to be in the presence of
the attacker it's understandable and
sadly one of the cases I know of even
though they had all kind of proof
against the representative you're a
little off track I'm kind of losing well
what I'm trying to say is that let's see
maybe I've wandered off on dogs
the point is when a person is in court
and scared very deeply frightened of the
person that they're trying to testify
against
they should have the same kind of
support somebody who's been given a dog
can have
um and which is you know a federally
allowed program in any place you can go
in court that dog can go with you I
verified that because last year one of
the criticisms a level that made by a
former judge no less was well we don't
let dogs in the court either
and I boy was he wrong
um this law does not say that you have
to prove that you are a victim that
hasn't been proved yet you have to go
through Court to prove that there was a
victim and there was an attacker so you
can't make that a criteria to get a
support person because you haven't
proven that it even happened yet
uh and if you don't what happened in the
case before that I referred to the
person walks scot-free because the judge
insisted that not only the the uh
not only the evidence
but the person he demanded that the
victim testify and she just couldn't
um
that is
obviously the wording does need to be
changed where it says that uh an
advocate
an nhca dsv advocate would be the person
I'm under the impression that all the
crisis centers are linked together in
members of the nhca dsv
um
The Advocate is very valuable and in the
case that I'm referring to the advocate
was present and had been very helpful
but there is no way an advocate that
you've met
to help you is the same as a deeply
strongly related person that is an
emotional support for you
so we're not advocating against
Advocates we're just saying they can't
um
excuse me
I do have a handout that shows you know
the proof that the proof that uh support
animals are guaranteed
access and I think that people deserve
thank you
any questions uh representative Nelson
thank you Mr Vice chair and thank you
honorable gay for taking my question I'm
a little confused because it seems to me
that the example that you're giving is a
may you address
uh well sadly the the lines get blurred
in family court so there can be some
real criminal activities
thank you oh you're good any further
questions
see you none thank you for your
testimony thank you uh see no more cards
to be back here at one
yeah no this was for uh this was uh yeah
bitties
okay
never ever again say this is just a very
any oversight by a judge to make that
determination
but for the rest of the time
whether it's Harmony Montgomery's mom or
somebody else who's asking for
information from the Department the
department shouldn't be able to squash
what records are being requested
and in one in section 170-g colon 8-a
right which is has to do with
confidential records by the department
the commissioner is granted Authority in
three places to deal with this right and
the and the third section is rules so
this addresses the two sections where
the commissioner can just arbitrarily
we're seeing a growing number of cases
where children right
um
may have been abused
um or are being abused either way right
and a parent's trying to find out what's
going on whether it's a contentious
whether it's a separation that already
happened and one parent wants to know
what's going on
the Department's not sharing the
information and that's the root cause
that needs to be solved in no other
place do we have effectively to use the
vernacular right the the fox guarding
the hen house the information is there
the department creates the information
but the commissioner can turn around and
say this information that we found we're
not going to share so this would open up
that making sure that there's an
independent oversight committee or in
this case the judicial branch over
overseeing the record sharing and then
would allow the commissioner sorry the
department to share the information in a
timely manner
that's it for the bill the need if
there's any questions please give me
please I'm willing to take them right
now
any questions for the representative
representative Raymond uh thank you um
chairman and uh thank you honorable
um the process is that a parent writes
to the division of children youth and
families and requests a copy of the
record but they have to wait until the
case is closed like that there's some
outcome to it they're not getting in
progress in progress notes is that
correct so the parent does in fact have
to request the records I don't know
whether there's rules about disclosure
during some court level thing
um
for the record right I had a I was
our family actually was accused um by
dcyf of neglect the judge ultimately
found that we were very good loving
parents and there was no evidence of any
type
um of any neglect of our of our family
but it took a fair amount of time to go
through the court to get the records as
opposed to going directly to dcyf I
couldn't request the records to dcyf I
ended up having to go through their
legal team to get the records right on
kind of as a Court Discovery but that
was already into the process of the
court so for that when you're in the
court system there may be other rules
about discovery on how records are
shared but if we haven't gotten there
why can't a parent have access to the
records right let's say
I'll use a hypothetical a child's in
school
comes home with a pretty nasty bruise
parent wants to know what happened
someone at the school makes a phone call
to dcyf that child is now taken in for a
medical examination where did this
bruise come from right was this done at
school was this done on sports or was
this done at home type thing
why can't the parent have access to
those records why
right we shouldn't allow the
commissioner just to turn around and say
no we're going to withhold sharing that
information okay uh
very uh thoughtful of you to share that
with us
um in this particular case
um you're asking that instead of writing
to the local office and saying I would
like a copy of my family's record with
dcyf you would like that's still the
process but then you want dcyf to have
to demonstrate to a judge if they say no
instead of the commissioner just saying
no we're not going to share the
information and we're aware of of cases
where that has happened
um the the commissioner would have to
petition the court for the ability to to
not share that information what's the
recourse now if someone were to be
denied access by the commissioner is
there like do they go to the Ombudsman
where do they go it's not real clear
it's a great question thank you it's not
real clear what happens when someone is
denied information do they have to go to
the court to get to order this right the
process gets really muddy very quickly
in no other case whether it's government
creating records and then not sharing
them okay where that same Department
gets to say no we're not going to share
them right typically it goes to the
judicial branch for the sole purpose of
being able to have an independent
oversight whether this is information
that could put the the child in further
danger and that's the that should be the
threshold right is this in the best
interests of the child disclosing this
information well the commissioner who
has that information wouldn't
necessarily be an unbiased person to
make that claim
the judge would
okay thank you I appreciate it
representative D Simone
sure I'm reading section one
parentheses open and close parentheses a
the department shall provide access to
the case records to the following
persons
petitions the court but there's no list
of persons what persons okay so you
would have to go back to the rest of
that section of Statute there's a list
may I sug follow up yeah may I suggest
that they'd be listed here as well
because it doesn't seem like the thought
was finished is my
point
um
there is a right the case records of the
department shall be confidential
um the record shall be available
um to there's a list of people further
down in this section and I want to find
it right
already laid out
so this is not the complete section of
170 g8-a right there there's it would be
two pages worth of text this is just two
sections of that text
um I can ask that the committee
researcher I can send it to you in
foreign
I'm sorry may I yeah go ahead I I can
get that my thought is that
the sentence just was not finished okay
and that's my concern I I prefer it to
be
more clear okay thank you thank you so
under two parentheses a there is
parentheses one through nine below that
the child the parent the guardian the
custody right another member of the
family employees of the department legal
counsel for dcyf there's a whole list of
people that are part of Who records are
disclosed to that's already past that
colon so the colon is the end of this
sentence but there's an entire list of
people and in some cases organizations
below that that have access to the
records
foreign
let me read that from the book here the
case records of the department shall be
confidential sub a the department shall
provide access to the case records to
the following persons and parents are
listed into Sub sub 2. unless the
commissioner or designee determines that
the harm to the child named in the case
record resulting from the disclosure
outweighs the need for the disclosure so
if the commissioner or one assigned
believes that releasing the records
would harm the child they shall not be
released that that's what we have that
is currently today is that a status quo
here
so in this case we have the executive
branch or right a supporting function of
the executive branch who's us with
administering the Justice side of things
and and enacting and administering the
policy who finds and produces the
records the problem is they also get
the say
um whether they're released or not and
normally the judicial process would kick
in then about an independent oversight
for record release
so in other words
if we say you're not going to get them
you're not going to get them you would
like that to be changed to if we want
them we get them unless you prove
otherwise
it's it's something let me reiterate
that slightly differently okay
if a if a parent or the child or the
list of one through nine request the
records the record shall be handed out
if the commissioner doesn't me believes
that these are in fact dangerous to the
best interest of the child or to right
could cause harm
the child the the design sorry the
commissioner designee can then say to
the court I have a reason I have good
evidence why these records should not go
out right now and I would like a judge
to confirm that and then the judge gets
to look at that evidence independently
to make sure that there could be no
got it
representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman thank you for being here in
your testimony today and for taking my
question
um I just the one question I have is
what
um my brain just totally like stalled
out on me
um
what would be the reasoning that the
parent if this is in a case like um
in somebody's case where they're trying
to either look and see if there is
findings for abuse or not
um what would be the reason that the
parent would have to have uh this report
before I mean seemingly the entire
investigation is done so I'm going to
use this
since it was Front Page News the case
study about Harmony Montgomery along the
way right where the mom had numerous
requests into the department for updates
what's going on those that information
wasn't being shared this went on for a
very long period of time
and unfortunately the lack of action in
some cases would have been obvious if
you had the records right would have
been something that she could have then
escalated the issue I think in terms of
transparency we want to make sure the
Department's doing the best possible job
and the way to make sure that's
happening is people who care about the
children right and there's a list of one
through nine that would be people and
groups and organizations that care about
their children can get access to the
rear to the records
the current system incentivizes if
there's a problem oh we messed up we
don't want to share that information and
I'm not saying the department does that
but it wouldn't the the currents the
current structure actually could allow
for that to happen because if there was
a mistake they wouldn't want to share it
as opposed to letting an independent
uh representative Raymond
thank you Mr chairman for indulging me
that questioning has led to another
question popping in my head
um and that is
um is there a way to
um address the goal of this which is to
have oversight of the answer no through
some other
mechanisms such as an appeals process
for someone who's told no if you request
a record and you're said and the
commissioner says no we don't want to
release it because it's harmful or
because the reports aren't ready or
whatever the reason is is there
um would it not be more efficient
instead of changing state law to
initiate a system within dcyf or within
the office of the child advocate or
someone else to take a look at this and
say okay I'm going to appeal this
decision of the commissioner
thank you for the question that is a
another way to address the same core
issue right I think both processes that
you just the one that's been proposed
here and what you just talked about
are allowing an independent agency in
this case the judicial branch or maybe
it's the child advocate office to be to
to do the review and it only questions
who prompts that action whether it's the
department saying I have information
that
well I we believe that this information
in this document here if release would
further harm the child right versus the
parent saying well I was just denied
right routinely I'm I'm now going to
appeal it either way there's going to be
that presentation before the judicial
branch and I think in most cases
the bulk of these are the information
should be shared there there needs to be
some judicial carve out that allows for
the commissioner and or designee to say
hey I have a concern
if this
it's a sexual abuse case or something
there's there's certain information here
that we don't want shared for some
reason we believe that this is going to
create further harm to the child we want
so both are acceptable process this is
just one way to solve it
representative Nelson
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um my question is just
um
are there any um
time frames or Time guidelines or
um
any
I'm just a little bit
concerned about
um
delays in being provided the information
so there are time frames
um
I believe it's 30 days and 60 days
there are some time frames in statutes I
need to go back and get you that answer
how that applies
um this section of Statute does I don't
believe has a timeline driving
disclosure of records and maybe that's
thank you and um I guess also
um thank you because I quickly skip um
scan it and I couldn't find it so I
appreciate that but also too would you
consider
um
a time frame for the petition and a time
frame
for a decision on this day like so my
question is can
um
can document just disclosure be delayed
because of a backup in the court system
and how could you prevent that from
happening
so theoretically it is possible right
that the court system could right
because they have their own schedule and
scheduling of a hearing
um
this might not the reason I did it this
way is if the Department's the one
saying these records are so important
and would potentially damage the child
they can go directly to the judge would
be a lot easier than scheduling it the
other way where the petition the family
starts the request now you're going to
have you have to schedule a court
hearing there's a bunch of other things
that happens making it even more
difficult time wise if an independent
judge turns around looks at the records
and says yes this I could see the
argument why the commissioner doesn't
want to release these these need to stay
confidential that might kick off an
appeal process to to kind of to
representative Raymond's question or
earlier comment about do we need an
appeal process
um I didn't get into the nitty-gritty in
terms of the details what I saw though
the fundamental problem that needs to be
solved is we have the same Department
overseeing their work being the one who
gets the ultimate Authority whether
their work should ever be disclosed and
and and we should do our best job
protecting the children and if that is
the goal of us as a state it would be
wise to make sure that if there's ever
a failure to act maybe or an
overreaction maybe
um a misdiagnosis something all of that
information is available and that it has
an independent oversight group
I will take and get back to you
representative Nelson on time frame I
got to go through it's been a couple
years since I've actually read through
all of 170. thank you appreciate it
any further questions for the
representative representative Bickford
thank you Mr chairman my uh concern with
this is it looks like
dcyf will go to the court and ask them
if they can
uh not we give it out but the parent
that wants it is not there so it's kind
of a one-sided Affair which is kind of
unusual in a court setting
so this thank you for the question it's
a great question that goes to should
there be an appeal process the first
review could be a judicial review of
this information and if the parent then
believes that that judicial review
wasn't done correctly then you could
kick off some sort of appeal
in the port system where the parent says
well the judge looked at it and they
came up with the same conclusion but
I've got to believe that the that the
judge looking at this would be is
supposed to be fair and impartial that
if the information is truly that
dangerous to release that
um the judicial review would be pretty
simple
follow up but dcyf has got there yeah
they're the ones that are going there
and saying by the way it's a step in the
right direction does it solve every case
maybe not right but at least we have the
chance that there's an independent
review today there is no independent
review the same agency producing the
information gets to say well trust me I
have this and it's really damaging to
the child but I'm not going to show you
what's here because I'm I've decided to
keep it hidden that doesn't that type of
thing doesn't work in our society in
terms of openness and transparency
that's why I said this should be a
reasonably non-partisan issue to make
sure that when there is information
that's available that it be given to the
list of nine nine people in groups and
only in the rare case where it would be
harmful to the child would it be kept
confidential and only when there's a
judicial review
to make that happen
thank you Representatives seeing no more
questions the chair recognizes Beth it
looks like Morgan from dcyf
not chair I am Beth margison I'm sorry I
have very bad handwriting so you're
going to be Beth Morganson on all of
these cards you filled out right yes I
am all day I'm going to be Beth margison
okay the part of Beth Morgan is now
played by Beth Moore just said thank you
oh you did it okay sorry that's good so
uh thank you chair and vice chair and
the members of the committee for the
opportunity to speak here tonight on
this today on this bill I just wanted to
give the the committee some background
um just sort of starting from going back
and then forward 170 g8a requires the
division to produce all records to the
people representative wholes exactly
right there are nine entities to which
records can be released the exemptions
from those records are things like third
party records doctors records school
records things that are submitted to
courts I forget what the other
exemptions are there is no exemption for
the division to not divulge information
that might be damaging to to it we do
not withhold that those go whatever is
in the case File that we have to furnish
to any of those entities goes out the
time frame for producing those records
is 60 days however the division is very
behind on records requests because we
have been trying to set up a records
request unit for years in order to
facilitate and expedite records to
individuals whose right it is to have
those records and we feel very strongly
about getting those records to them
as to the legislation itself
the division does not withhold records
unless there is an open assessment going
on or a concurrent criminal
investigation at the request of the
police when the investigate when a
criminal investigation or an assessment
is closed then we're able to to release
records that is the harm to the child
it's whether we need to make sure that
the assessment is done without any kind
of
I wouldn't say interference but just
making sure that the assessment is done
by the division and if there's any
criminal investigation that is is part
of that you know is sort of going
alongside the division the assessment
then with that's the only time that we
actually withhold uh releasing records
so I have any questions if anyone like
to would uh ask me something I mean
there are there is this is a records
request but there are instances where
the division is in court with a parent
and uh parents are actually provided
Discovery and that is a fuller uh set of
case records that does include third
party records
um so that is that in that case the
parent if the parent is court involved
with dcyf they do receive all of the
records because it's discovery
let me read section B after the nine
people mentioned section B says the
department shall disclose information
from case records or provide access to
case records to the following persons or
entities I will jump down to sub 4 the
person or entity with whom the child
resides if that person is not the
child's parent guardian or custodian
continues if such information or access
is not harmful to the child and is
necessary in order to enable the person
or entity to act to evaluate provide
services and so on
I think the question that is begged is
who determines
um harmful
that is the commissioner harmful is an
open assessment in that case um I don't
have the statute in front of me but I
believe four is our foster parents and
we are allowed to release limit
information to foster parents in order
to help with the provision of services
for children and the key point in that
statute is the department shall it's
mandatory we have to do it
the only block on you have to release is
if in your determination to do so would
to be harmful yes so it's a part it's a
positive push statement here it's not an
allowance you must do it we must do it
then we have a I have a quandary because
the bill before me at least in my mind
seems to indicate this hasn't been done
at least in some instances and the
um Prime sponsor wishes to make
something happen so I'm not quite sure
why we're here I don't either I think
that's probably a better question for
the sponsor I'm going to ask the him
that in a minute when we're done asking
you I'll give him another bite at the
representative Raymond
uh thank you and um thank you so much
Miss Morganson for being here
um you said that there's a bit of a
delay happening on records requests um
and I remember that from my time
although five ten years ago
um that it took some time but sometimes
we had parents come in and read the file
or whatever do you know what that delay
is on average Statewide I don't okay I
don't
it's uh but I think it's we're past the
60 days I just know that we have you
know the attorneys have to do the review
of the records before they're sent out
to make sure that those those other
records are not included in it
um and uh it you know we're
short staffed in the legal services
right now so and then uh follow-up
regarding follow-up thank you so much
um regarding open assessments and open
concurrent police investigations I
recall that a number of cases have
concurrent police investigations and
there's uh at least in Nashville there
was a high level of cooperation between
the police and dcyf what would happen if
dcyf were to release records while
there's a police investigation
I don't know if you can say generally
what would happen I think everything's
on a case-by-case basis I I don't I mean
again I don't want to generalize because
I don't know the full landscape here but
I think it would be unlikely that the
division would actually release records
while there was a criminal investigation
ongoing okay thank you Mr representative
long thank you Mr chairman a couple of
questions have I made following uh
representative uh Raymond's question
um
would you assume that the update of
Investigations would also be released or
would that be another request
If This Were to pass and and you would
be required to give that information
well as I understand it we would have to
petition the court to make an
independent verification as to whether
or not we can release the records okay
and if it were released would
updated investigations be uh
required in your opinion or would that
any update would have to go back to
court well generally when we do records
requests we generally include all the
information you know sometimes parents
will say this referral but we'll find
out that there's other records or some
you know and we generally will include
all the records um we you know we have
11 district offices and oftentimes we
will have
um cases that go across all the district
offices and so we have a policy in our
in our office that the whatever office
gets the request has to gather all other
requests from other district offices I'm
gonna fall off I mean this chairman
thank you
um
so a physical health
entity would get this information are
there are there deductions for example
if the child had a psychological
evaluation would the physical health
doctor get that that would be for a
child generally you know I I don't have
the statue in front of me that would be
for a child who is in our custody or we
have perhaps legal supervision for and
we're trying to provide services for
them we would give live ended
information to that doctor to provide
services when we're doing just a records
request I know this is a little
confusing it's there was no case the
assessment closed we handed over
generally to the parents if we do have
information from a medical provider we
can't release that under this current
statute but what we do is we provide the
parent with the name address the
information that they would need so that
they could go get that that information
generally is from their own child's
pediatrician so it's it's they generally
are able to get it okay thank you
thank you very much I would like to call
Representative holback because I do have
this um conundrum here the given section
B of 170 G8 uh that the department shall
disclose information
consideration necessitated this bill
representative
thank you for the question
um so key study of one I hate case
studies level one I'm an engineer I like
looking at larger data sets than one so
maybe I'm maybe our family was the
anomaly and the other
99.9999 of families that have
experienced their
an interaction with dcyf have never had
any issues getting information from the
Department
I thought this would be pretty simple
the statute was pretty obvious right I
should be able to request the
information it there was it was withheld
in our case
and in talking with some other families
I'm now understanding that there's a
reluctance to share the information that
the department has
so yes it says shall
but there's a carve out that allows the
department
today to turn around and say we're going
to ignore the shall because we can via
the Commissioner's Office determining
that this is not right determines right
that's the word that's in statute
determines that this could harm the
child but there's no metric no standard
for the word determines there and
there's no independent oversight
I don't see how we do this in other
branches when there's a when there's a
decision-making body in other branches
and someone says that's not fair we
typically kick it over to the judicial
branch for an independent evaluation
representative it goes back to my
question under 178 g eight a uh excuse
me B that the department shall disclose
unless and it's the unless is not
harmful to the child
and that begs the question as to what
constitutes that and who makes that
decision so it is the people making the
decisions themselves without independent
review am I tracking with you here yes
okay
anything you want to add I think I'm all
set okay good thank you and that's it in
terms of pink cards and don't run away
because we're going to start something
else this ends the hearing on
uh whatever we are having a hearing on
497. 497 and now we open the hearing on
what's next and I'm all over the place
here
5 35 open the hearing on HP 535 and
representative Hull
thank you chairman members of children
family law for the record
representative hole Dunbarton former
member of children family law about a
decade ago the bill before you has to do
with whether a child
and child in our statutes is everybody
from 0 through 18 and I will bring I
will come back to that point is entitled
to have their view represented in court
um I believe the committee researcher
has turned in a packet that looks like
this that you guys were given I would
like to see if I can get the electronic
copy of this yes that packet
I would like you to flip to this chart
here
page I don't know about four four
there's a large map of the US it's
another page four because there's
several page fours
it's the fourth piece of paper in our
fifth piece of paper or so in the packet
foreign
I discovered the issue that this bill
tries to address
paid last year
in that case we had a teenager who
wanted to have their own view shared in
the courtroom and that wasn't allowed
and I said well wait a minute so we
ended up hiring an attorney for him that
was the easiest way to take care of it
we hired an attorney we paid the bills
and he got to go talk to the attorney
and the attorney showed up in court on
our behalf on our son's behalf but I
found out in in speaking with this
attorney and others that were one of the
few states that does not allow children
to have representation in court there
are apparently considered a substandard
class of citizens and I think that's
offensive
okay
a 15 year old is very capable of sharing
how they feel about what's going on in
why can't they get access to counsel
well they can't pay for it well how do
we deal with that with the rest of
society if the person can't pay for a
council we at the state level provide
now this is different for a two-year-old
I understand that but in this case we
don't okay we have Casa volunteers we
appoint gals but the there is no one who
is actually arguing on behalf of the
child's wishes themselves the casa can
do their best job but they're not
obligated to represent
the child's wishes they're obligated by
Statute today to represent what they
think is the best interest of the child
the child is really without any counsel
and then the one place that it does show
up in our statutes is that the
dispositional hearing well we're pretty
far down the process and if this is a
reassignment from a family to a foster
family
or from one parent to another there
could be a lot of a lot of situations
the child really doesn't get any say
they just
get shoved around and I don't think
that's fair so
the issue here is a lot of states have
started to go down the process where the
child is entitled to legal counsel to
represent their wishes we don't do that
even Massachusetts does that I would
argue that the best thing we could do
and maybe it's not for all ages I can I
can have that conversation right there's
a big difference between a five-year-old
and a 15 year old in terms of being able
to represent their views and
understanding what's going on
but by the time we get to a teenager
they should have their say they should
be allowed to discuss what's going on
and how it impacts their lives because
no matter what happens at the end of the
day the decisions that the court is
making the decisions that all the other
interested parties are making
affects them significantly so they
should have their say in court
that's it
thank you for your presentation I have a
question here in section
Roman 2
yeah
um after the strikeout the court May
appoint an attorney go down four more
lines in addition the court May appoint
an attorney but then go down to the
bottom of the page under 490 d3a
shall be entitled to representation how
do you harmonize the court may do it
with the court better do it so this is a
great question
um I'm sure I was not the only
legislator who put in an LSR who in the
week between Christmas and New Year saw
various redrafts and whatever and oh
please sign off before we get this bill
done and I'm not blaming them they they
had a huge number of requests but this I
think we need to do a scrub of the
languages to make sure the shells and
Maize are in sync in this case the goal
would be if the child the child shall be
appointed counsel and
um that may cost the state some money
but we should allow all citizens access
to an attorney to represent their view
in court so when you scrub the language
and come back with an amendment when we
exec this we could assume that the
language the court May appoint will be
moved to the courtship yes also on page
two it talks about fiscal notes again it
was a busy time
they were not ready has the fiscal notes
since come forward I have not seen the
fiscal note it is an FN Bill I'm sure
it's going to finance because it would
impact State spending so that being the
case I'm sure it's coming to a second
committee this is probably an early bill
it's not been given to me as an early
bill but I could assume they might
change their mind so given the
possibility we may have to get it out
the door by the middle of February would
you come back as soon as you could with
an amendment the language based on this
and anything else that we might
absolutely anybody else want to help him
representative long
thank you Mr chairman uh you brought up
a good point
you know appointed attorney for a
two-year-old
um so should
we Define that what you know it's a
great representative long thank you it's
a great question and there is a there is
a point where a child has enough
capability to be able to make
recommendations and understand what's
going on and a two-year-old is not at
the same place as a 12 year old right
there are some guidelines in other
statutes about when children are allowed
to testify in court for instance I
believe that's 13 or 14 I have to go
back and look at the statutes there are
some other things but
um we can we can move the bar from 18
down what the right threshold is is
clearly something worth debating whether
that's 16 14 12 10 8 2 is probably at
the other end of the spectrum right
um at that point they're not capable of
fully taking care of themselves so
a window that seems reasonable somewhere
between 8 and 14 I don't know what the
right number is but there is a point in
time where children are cognizant of
what's going on around them to make
well-informed decisions in something
that dramatically is going to impact
their life very good thank you
representative Raymond
uh thank you chairman and thank you
representative for being here
um are you wanting the court to appoint
or have the ability to appoint
representation for the child prior to a
disposition on a case so currently they
get if they're in foster care or
whatever they get a casa or you know a
parent could get a jail once there is a
finding of abuser neglect and a case is
opened but up to that point the dcyf
hasn't determined the court hasn't
determined abuse or neglected so you're
asking for representation to them before
a case has started so so my
understanding of the process having gone
and throw it only once I don't claim to
be an expert yet
um is there is a preliminary hearing and
then there's an adjudicatory hearing and
then there is a dispositional hearing
yes
um clearly by the adjudicatory hearing
the child should have representation
because that's where the facts of what's
going on are discussed and the child may
have information that would be relevant
to the adjudication decision as opposed
to just the dispositional this is
drafted all the way back to the
preliminary hearing because that's where
in our personal case
and I don't want to I don't want the
bill to be about our personal case but
that's where the case went off the rail
significantly okay
um and a little bit of additional
information in that hearing would have
been very different
um
so I think it's worthwhile that there at
least be the door opened for at the
preliminary hearing but definitely move
the bar back from dispositional to the
adjudicatory face and quick follow-up
follow-up
um I'm five years out of date Now with
uh and Casa so I apologize but back when
I was involved in DCF and Casa there was
the youth and Court protocols where
um children were invited to all of the
Court hearings and I I know that that
was happening because I drove some
myself and had an opportunity to speak
to judge like pretty much whenever they
want or otherwise meaningfully
participate by writing a letter or I
mean we had two-year-olds drawing
pictures for the judge is that not
happening now so my understanding the
rules are slightly different and there
is a provision I believe it's 13
um the dcif worker or the rate we can
find out from
um with the committee researcher but
there is a threshold and it's either 13
or 14 before the child is entitled to be
appear in court for the first time so
the there's now a Prohibition there you
can set up
um
and forgive me I don't know the legal
term but an appearance with the judge
directly
um
we actually petitioned for said thing
dcyf came back and said no
and it would be front page news if I use
the language they said
um about their reasons it was it was
appalling
so
allowing the child
they're a person at the end of the day
we we should protect the children in the
state to the best of our ability if a
child says
I don't think this is fair there's
something wrong I want to talk to the
judge we should make sure that happens
in any any way possible and in our case
that couldn't happen
um rarely do you get to file a piece of
legislation
for a family member but in this case
sorry I'm a little emotional I do
because I watch firsthand the trauma
okay that my child experienced through
all of this because he was denied access
any further questions for the
representative thank you
my suggestion is since you have to go
testify in another committee that if
driving home tonight we get this
brainstorm that begins with oh I should
have asked him
um would you welcome them to email or
call you absolutely while you're
undergoing your little Bill scrubbing
absolutely so please contact me we can
add some of our wisdom okay good thank
you everyone
that's Norwegian isn't it
actually Scottish
well I'm Scottish and I know where a lot
of my ancestors came from is from Norway
so
I am actually Norwegian marjison is my
husband's name whoa but he is not
Norwegian
so as I understand it it's Scottish but
but we'll have to talk later exactly
so again uh thank you chair Vice chair
and members of the committee for
allowing me to speak here today I am
Beth margison either Norwegian or
Scottish and I am here on behalf of dcyf
to provide testimony on this bill
um a couple of things just sort of
working backwards again uh
representative Poole is is correct in
that
um
the
[Music]
children
or perhaps it was you representative
Raymond I'm mature but uh according to
protocols that were developed between
Casa and other people in the model core
project children 14 and above in the
dispositional phrase going forward can
speak to the judge directly and that can
sometimes be off the record with their
Casa present tell the judge anything
that they speak want to or they can
speak directly in open court it's
generally up to the judge to decide how
he wants to take that testimony and also
yes children as young as two can send
pictures and
um information to the judge to tell them
how they're doing I think the consensus
was the 14 was probably the youngest age
it was children it is important for
children to have voice in court and
proceedings but that they had reached a
physician sufficient maturity to speak
in court at that age and notably the age
of consent for adoption for a child is
also 14 years
the division would have a lot of
concerns about having a child present
during an adjudicatory hearing
the division has never called the child
to the witness in any kind of
adjudicatory hearing I remember one
child was asked to testify and a judge
would not allow It ultimately who is
allowed to speak in a courtroom is up to
a judge but in general children do have
a voice when they are over 14 years from
the dispositional phase of the case on
um as to the the merits of the
legislation
um representative who is right that New
Hampshire is but one of a few states
that do not have representation for
children
the vision is not necessarily opposed to
that not opposed to providing
representation for children our concerns
are is that it would be extremely
expensive the pool of attorneys that
would likely be able to work with
children would be somewhat uh small and
there would be a lot of conflict with
parents attorneys and that parents
attorneys would also be representing
individuals in the same case so you
would probably see a lot of conflicts in
their interest it would cost quite a bit
of money again we're not opposed to that
but we think that in terms of the money
that we need to to build up our system
and improve it at this time that money
probably would be better spent on
assessment treatment and services for
children in but it is correct and as the
committee your committee researcher has
noted in her in her materials which I
haven't had a chance to go through we
are but one of a few states that do not
represent children to have appoint
attorneys for children
another issue with the with the uh
legislations that is drafted is that
where the child's expressed interest
conflict with any recommendation we're
concerned that this could be this could
be potentially trivial things which are
big things to a child
limitations on cell phone use curfew use
that this could perhaps
first of all it would probably certainly
create more litigation but that every
single aspect of where the child wants
to do something would become a you know
a lawsuit based not a lawsuit but it
would actually create litigation it
would prolong permanency it would make
for a very difficult case to to
um to handle going forward you know
again dispositional orders
um the the bigger portions of the case
the bigger parts of the case placement
Treatment Services psycho valves
uh visitation with parents and whatnot
those are things that are routinely
hashed out in court not only the
dispositional hearing but at the three
six and nine month hearings prior to
getting to the permanency hearing at
that point the child is represented by a
gal no I'm sorry the child does have a
gal or a casa appointed to the child to
represent their best was it with their
best interests
um
I think that's about all we have to say
on the legislation if I'm here to take
any questions if anyone has them
representative long thank you Mr
chairman
do you ever recommend recommended age
If This Were to pass at what
I I I don't I don't think you can put an
age on it because I don't think other
states have put an age on it
um I think you either appoint attorneys
for children or or you don't all right
thanks
yes representative ball
thank you Mr chairman
um a question about the casa is it
possible for the casa to represent both
issues the issue of what the child would
like versus the um what the casa would
like so that they could present both
sides of the issue because the casa does
spend a lot of time with the child and
I'm sure they've talked about what the
child wants worth
versus what the cost of fields would be
in the child's best interest I'm a
little reluctant to answer that because
I don't represent Casa in general I will
say it cost us here okay good if I found
a casa over your left shoulder nodding
up and down and she were to fill out a
pink card could we take her expert
testimony I would defer to the expert
testimony of Casa I was a casa just so
you know that's why I'm asking because
it seems like it would have been a
stretch it out while she's filling out
her card okay
I think that's all I can do Mr well you
know yeah I kind of I can fill some time
in
um given the fact a lot of states listed
as doing this are states that we could
call
impecunious or stingy or frugal
they seem to have found the money to
make it possible so I wonder how much
money this would actually cost after all
I don't know we don't have a fiscal note
on the bill so I I actually I really
don't know okay
the chair recognizes
the person who is signing the pink card
and is handing it to representative
Bickford
who is walking it up to me
and um if we could vacate the seat just
momentarily
thank you and I apologize we recognize
Marcia sink from Manchester to speak to
the question yes um thank you for the
opportunity
um I'm Marcia sink I'm the CEO of Casa
of New Hampshire and
um to fill in a couple of the blanks
there is uh there are Court protocols
that allow any child to attend court and
I just wanted to say that our judges are
encouraging and inviting children to
attend their Court hearings and it would
be as as
attorney Martin represented it is after
the dispositional phase of the hearing
so it is during those review hearings
when a child can be invited to attend
the court hearing also it under the
guardian ad litem rules any gal whether
it's a casa or a pay gal is obligated to
bring to the Court's attention when the
child's wishes are in direct conflict
with their best interest and we are
required to do that under again the
guardian ad litem rules so there is that
opportunity for the court to be made
aware at any point in time what the
child's best what their wishes are there
is also the opportunity for the
appointment of an attorney for those
children if the court determines that it
is necessary so we have right now about
20 cases on our caseload which our
caseload right now is 639
Active Child Abuse and neglect cases
there are about 20 cases right now on
our caseload where there has been an
attorney appointed for the child for a
variety of reasons and
um but that's that's at the request of
the typically of the casa Guardian Ad
Litem or other guardian ad litem
and yet that being granted we are
colored white in this map one of the few
so although let's stipulate all of those
things are true what what could we do
perhaps that we have not been doing in
order to change our color on the map if
we desired to well I think the resource
issue is a huge issue for for the state
the way this
proposed legislation reads the way I'm
reading it is that in fact it's looking
for an attorney's attorney appointment
for every child who comes into the
family court system which goes which is
much broader than just those coming in
under the 169 C statute which is just
the abuse and neglect proceedings so
that that opens up number one a huge
door to other types of cases marital
cases also are heard in the in the um in
the family court so but our caseload
alone right now we have over over a
thousand children on our caseload and
again this looks at appointing an
attorney for every single child I beg to
differ the section 2A of the bill before
us in cases involving a neglected or
abused child
yes it states that in the beginning but
I believe it further goes on to
um but I could have read it misread it
yeah maybe I am too because down in 490
d3a in all proceedings in the judicial
Family Division
a minor child who is the subject of such
proceedings which begs definition so
that may broaden it
um considerably so we may have a
conflict possibly there I will give him
a call on that let's just say that that
is not the case and it's only in cases
involving neglected or abused child that
should bring the number considerably
down correct if if in fact it's we have
639 open cases but involved on all those
open cases are over a thousand children
so
um and again the way
we're seeing reading this is that it
would be an attorney appointed for each
of those individual children and
sometimes our sibling groups are
um need have very different needs and
and desires um the other thing I would
say is that the first part which in the
um Roman 2 uh the elimination of of the
appointment only being able to happen
during after the dispositional orders we
would ask I mean we would what we would
love to see is that broadened that at
any point as as they're suggesting here
that at any point during the preceding
uh the request for an attorney could be
made by the guardian ad litem so you
would approve of the strikethroughs yes
representative Levesque
with uh it's been mentioned before about
kids sending in letters and drawings to
the judges has that helped a lot when uh
dealing with children's cases like in
abuse and neglect and helping figure out
what's especially for younger kids like
what's going on in their mind and seeing
that it's been it's been remarkable
really
um how I think one of the the things
that we've that's been so powerful is
the relationship then between the judge
and the child and how
um attending court hearing or writing
the judge a letter sort of demystifies
things for some of our kids
um
I could share a real quick little story
now yes oh okay so we had um we had a
six-year-old little boy who was coming
home to his foster home and um asking
his mum if after school if he could
watch Judge Judy on TV this was a while
ago and Mom kind of foster mom kind of
allowed him to do it for a couple of
days and then said but wait a second how
about Sesame Street today and he said
well I wanna I wanna look for Bob my
casa volunteer in the courtroom
and so the casa made arrangements for
the judge to meet the child and um you
know played beanie babies or something
on the floor with a child but just but
that demystification of and for some of
our older children who are given the
opportunity to talk to a judge and they
feel they've been disempowered by not
being able to be present finally
um can be there and feel like their
voices are truly heard I draw the line
at watching Night Court all right yep
I'm good with that too yeah it's back by
the way yeah
have you talked to representative hole
about this bill we have not
I might suggest it would really kind of
improve it if you would okay
um
I'm not going to rat you out to him so
it's in the book of reps and I think
he's on to something here and he told me
over the lunch hour that it's a rough
draft and he invoked the I'm going to
scrub this provision
so I think this could really improve it
and I think there are there are certain
situations and certain types of cases
where appointment for a child
the division talked about 14 and older
or some of our children are youth that
are in out of stone out of state
placements
um sometimes their voices are ones that
could really help and have an attorney
who's advocating for them representative
D Simone is it for the CEO or for the
attorney are you attorney too no okay
good the CEO attorney which one I would
like to ask the CEO a question please do
isn't it true that
the younger the child the less apt they
I mean to do two-year-olds know how to
lie do one-year-olds know how to lie I'm
not a clinician but I'd be hard-pressed
to
um unless they've really been coached
follow-up please yeah I mean yes you may
as as young as a child is
if they were to be appointed an attorney
and have the assistance of a casa
wouldn't it Aid them Aid the court in
determining abuse and neglect to the
I'm I'm not sure I guess I
what I'm trying to get at it
may I follow up follow up what I'm
trying to get at is we've had discussion
and questions about age limitations
I'm not
sure that I'm in tune with an age
limitation especially when it comes to
abuse and neglect and the ability of a
very young child to report what's
happening to them in a variety of ways
they don't have to be able to verbalize
yes this is what happened to me they can
do it by hand motions
pictures
whatever is that correct I we don't do
investigationary investigative work on
our cases that's really dcyf's job so
and I'm not a clinician so I'm I'm sort
of it's kind of a murky area for me to
be entertaining thank you for sure
absolutely
representative long thank you Mr
chairman thank you for your testimony
sure um do you see any duplication of
Casa specifically not
not a guardian Adel item appointed but
it costs are appointed Guardian Apple
item
um or a possible conflict with an
attorney of the child because you're the
best interest of a child the attorney
would be the best interest of the child
well do you see where it may conf yeah
yeah I guess that there is that a
possibility I think um if the if the
attorney is appointed as Council for
they're really
um sharing what the child wants so it's
which is can be and can be very
different from what the casa would be
representing as what's in their best
interest
um and I think so I think there there is
that clear Line in the Sand that should
be adhered to
um but there may potentially be conflict
I would think um thank you and maybe
that's part of the point here is that
section two in cases involving where the
child's expressed interests conflict
with the recommendation of the Guardian
Ad Litem you do have by definition here
oppositional that's right and that's
when we're required under the guardian
ad litem rules to
um share that with the court
repeatedly if need be two anyone else
representative McMahon thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you Ms Ms sink do I
get that right yes thank you uh two
questions for you um we have received a
report here and it said uh what
separates us as the
chair in the uh chairman McPherson
Pearson stated was that New Hampshire
was in is not part of states that
provide representation but it says here
um in its statement says it doesn't
guarantee the right to counsel although
we would have the option
do you uh my first question based on
that is should we guarantee the right to
counsel as part of this bill
I I would I would suggest that well I
think as as I said earlier I don't think
it's necessary on all cases
um I do think at times there are certain
types of cases where attorney
representation for example we deal with
immigration cases
um at times of children who are trying
to get their green card they need they
need an attorney to help them through
that process so we've we've had pro bono
support from some immigration attorneys
to help that happen but there are
certain types of cases where I think
um legal representation for the child
could be a valuable thing for them but I
wouldn't say all cases understood one
follow-up Mr chairman thank you thank
you sir specific to the bill it's it's
focusing on abuse and neglect
by by narrative
uh you referred to protocols for any
child to attend court within your
construct of how you do business is
language that
was within the protocol should should
any of that be applicable or applied to
the bill that is to be adjusted as the
chair has recommended that's an
interesting idea
um I don't know if the division feels
how they feel about that but um
there may be and I I guess I never
looked at it through that haven't looked
at through that lens of is there a
protocol that could be incorporated in
this
um just one final clarification thanks
Mr chairman
um can you provide what your those
Protocols are there in writing yeah so I
would love to be at the same
intelligentia level you are on that
issue sure you can make an informed
decision sure yeah
or I'm sure
um the court could share those as well
so they are a document that we is used
regularly and would you be prepared to
share that with the committee yes okay
good thank you
I think we have a member of the
committee that has already
found the materials we require your
honor
they are that will not put you out of a
job However the fact no he's done that
too well they are in the court website
yes yes Miss Miss sink knows very well
that I would never put her out of a job
but yes they're on the court website if
you just Google protocols relative to
Children and Youth in court New
Hampshire
um it goes through RSA 169 C and all of
the protocols could you send that to me
directly so I maybe committee send it to
the committee
CFL at you know okay
thank you any other questions for the
CEO
thank you so much aren't you glad you
came today I didn't expect to do it I'm
glad you came today thank you very thank
you all for the work you do thank you
yes
she's back if you have any further
questions anybody has any further
questions
representative DeSimone
the question that I asked the CEO and
could not be answered I noticed you were
I was smiling because I'm also not a
clinician
um so uh we
minor age children do not testify the
information that has that about the
child whether it's abuse or neglect
comes in through the cpsw who has
conducted her assessment by talking to
the child the parents and any other sort
of collateral contact
so uh we do not allow children to
testify in proceedings
and I would not want the division would
not be supportive of uh any any change
to the law that would require child that
children Could children should
participate in their cases they didn't
need a voice but from the dispositional
phase on not to be involved with the
fact-finding surrounding what has
happened to them you would also asked
about you know and I'm not a clinician
so I'm going a little bit out on a limb
here but about whether or not children
lie if they've been coached uh generally
I
the division cannot repeatedly question
children
they will actually refer them to a was
the Child Advocacy Center for and also
do forensic interviews of them
and I think this consensus is is that a
child who has been coached that becomes
somewhat apparent
um on a further interview because they
just
you know they I don't want to say this
about kids but they can't keep the story
straight you know it's
um when a child is consistent about an
event to two or three different people
that is compelling
again we do not repeatedly question
children about things that happen to
them thank you that's what I was looking
for okay thank you any further questions
you know it's so hard to get good
lutefisk in New Hampshire
my wife almost fainted when I told her
how it was made
yeah the chair recognizes Attorney
um thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee uh Richard head
government Affairs coordinator for the
judicial branch
um and I apologize I did come in late so
I did not have an opportunity to hear
the sponsor and I apologize I was
testifying in another committee
um we do as written
um have some concerns we don't have any
issues and we're not providing any
testimony on part one of the bill there
are two parts to this bill part one
um talks about it talks about the
express conflict with and adds any
recommendation and deletes four
dispositional dispositional orders we
have no input or testimony on that and
don't have any concerns
part two of the of the bill is a new
section in RSA 490d and and there are
some questions earlier about
um this being related to abuse and
neglect 490d is the statute that creates
Family Division so everything in Family
Division is 490d 490d just establishes
that so if and we would appreciate if
there was some narrowing of that so that
there's a specific issue abuse and
neglect or what it may be that'd be
placed in that section 490d would
suggest that every child in Every Family
Division case is entitled by a matter of
right to it to a lawyer
um the other aspect of the bill that has
as written became is is very unclear is
it doesn't talk about
how that lawyer is being brought to that
child how they're connecting who's
paying how sort of a processed a new
Standalone sentence that has no
particular connection to a court
um referral a court order and and a
payment Source
um so unsure in terms of what is
intended there we would have a great
deal of concern if the parties were
selecting or a party was selecting a
lawyer for a child where the there's a
significant opportunity to manipulate
that child in the proceeding so if a
party is paying for the attorney and
that party then has a has some form of
relationship with the attorney
it creates significant issues in terms
of of the independence of that lawyer
the child
and within the proceeding
but as written and it's a simple
Standalone sentence that seems to be
almost jurisdictional it just says if a
lawyer appears for a child the court has
no right
to to interfere with that and at that
point we have concerns just who's paying
for that lawyer what's the relationship
of the lawyer to the to a party in the
proceeding or to someone outside of the
parties but who may still have a role
in sort of affecting how that child is
is being presented so just significant
concerns as written we're always happy
to work with a sponsor with the
advocates in terms of additional
language or changing uh or modifying the
bill but as written we would suggest
itl but that doesn't mean that there
can't be changes that that improve it
um and we'd be happy to work with with
the committee and the sponsor to do that
yeah counselor while you were at another
meeting the prime sponsor opened up by
saying this is really a draft job this
was done on the fast and I trust that
now he who is at another committee will
review the the
I almost said tape I don't know what
it's called now but the you know
recording of this hearing to pick up the
various comments some of these issues I
think he's quite aware of
there's some good stuff in here and I
think he's very amenable to uh rewriting
with the input of people who've been
testifying today terrific and I
appreciate that and again apologize for
for being late in coming into the
hearing and I don't know I know back in
the day there were the work sessions
were created I don't know if the if the
chair has any interest in in doing a
work session on this bill given sort of
the number of people that they may have
been interested My Hope Is that they'll
key into him at this point and he will
produce a draft Amendment and perhaps
some of us might take a look at it I do
work sessions differently than some
chairs
great
um with that I've concluded my testimony
if there any other questions I'd be
happy to answer any uh questions of
counselor
had representative
Raymond
thank you chairman and um thank you
um attorney hid
um I have a question and it's kind of a
general legal lease kind of question so
in this in section two here it says well
section one under
um Roman numeral two it says an attorney
to represent the interest of a child and
today in testimony many people have
talked about the best interest of a
child and so now it's gotten me thinking
about what's the difference
legally speaking
between the interest of the child and
the best interest of a child like
what what what's a demarcation there so
I
thank you for the question I think the
the demarcation I might make differently
best interest of the child is the legal
standard for the judge to apply when
making a decision relative to the to the
child and that's laid out statute and
and I don't want to sort of are you
going through the statute partly because
I don't have in front of me I think the
testimony was
um the difference between what are the
best interests of the child which is
done through testimony in the
investigation and and the process and
what the child wants and what the child
wants can uh be dramatically different
than the best interest of the child
um you know child children obviously are
not always interested in their long-term
best interest but something that's
happening tomorrow
um or or now so you know it those two
are very different concepts you know the
interests of the child in the best
interest of the child
um I I don't think there's a legal
difference per se I think best interest
of the child is the standard that that
we're applying when evaluating the facts
expertise and and reports as courts
um when making decisions
may not answer a question I apologize if
it didn't
inline one of 2A in cases involving a
neglected or abused child under this
chapter with the child's expressed
interests conflict with any
recommendation of the gal I we've been
circling around that just now that the
child's expressed interest could be I
want to have a pizza at midnight and the
gal says no way I I thought the earlier
comment from DC wife was was appropriate
in terms of any does mean any uh and it
become and can become quite trivial
um
so I I think I think that's a fair point
we're just not taking a position in
terms one way the other have input in
terms of what the right language should
be and yet changing the word there too
the child's best interests
kind of to me May moderately
disenfranchise the child from having a
different opinion from a gal because if
the gal thinks this is the best interest
of the child then it really doesn't
matter what the expressed interest of
the child is and to me that's just a
little bit too much pushing away so I
don't think and and I think I better
understand the question that was asked
before you know I I would
I would say one represents the interest
of the child is a want of the child as a
practical matter in terms of of that
sentence in terms of the best interest
of the child it's not only the guardian
ad litem report that obviously is a
significant contributor to the
information that is received by the
court but there may be other information
and experts or factual testimony that's
presented that are taken collectively
together to do for the for the court to
make an ultimate decision on what are
the best interests of the child the
guardian ad litem is a significant but
only one aspect
um in in terms of that decision making
but that would then render the child's
interests
irrelevant the child's expressed
interests so they're not a participant
in that group I'm looking for a word
between expressed and best
where the child does have a say and it
may not necessarily be what the gal
wants and that's tough on the gal in a
few cases maybe so I think the if you
look at the rule that was referenced
um
earlier in terms of of one of the
obligations of the guardian of item and
Casa is that if the guardian and this is
what the rule says if a guardian ad
litem is aware that a recipient of the
services disagrees with a recommendation
being made by the guardian ad litem the
guardian ad litem shall fully advise the
appointing Court of this fact I think
that that is good language in terms of
good language of what I think you're
trying to address that's just for
reference purpose it's gal rules Jal
504.01
thank you that's very helpful great
we have one final pink card and after
that I will be closing the hearing and
the chair recognizes
Betty gay
The Honorable Betty gay
I'll try to wear that proud also an
alumnus of this organization as I recall
yes
um alumna excuse me
I am an alumni and alumni a oh okay
plural AE masculine U.S you may continue
okay I'm just going to give you some
observations from working with children
who have had bad experiences in Family
Court
I share the same concern that attorney
had just expressed about attorneys being
appointed for children who's paying them
because
that can have a lot to do with what the
attorney recommends
it also is the same problem that we have
now with court appointed gals
so I'm not surprised to see that some
child children have expressed a
different opinion from the gal that they
were assigned and have heard some pretty
bad horror stories so
um it's the same situation who's paying
the gal often has the most Sway in the
decisions of the gal the recommendations
of the gal I really don't like to hear
it said that
we can't afford to be fair
I've heard this excuse before on
recommended changes in the court system
while we can't afford it well we're
guaranteed rights
they didn't put it in the Constitution
either one that we don't get the rights
if the government doesn't feel like
paying for them
so that's our job is to fight for the
um
trying to make sure that I don't repeat
some things
um
I'm curious too that on lines 15
when it says the minor child who is the
subject of such proceedings
is they referring right then to this
subject of neglected and abused children
because if it is that needs to be
specified
because otherwise it does sound like all
minor children shall be entitled to
representation by counsel well right now
almost all children who get involved in
Family Court like in a divorce
proceedings
there's no choice they get assigned a
gal
only the court doesn't have to pay for
it
so they can be very generous in ordering
and then the parents get stuck paying
and often the services can just go on
and on and on and on so that's another
subject right for
reform
so many bad experiences have been
reported to me
when the gal does not represent the
child so I don't have any solutions here
I just see some places that we could
tighten up the wording to be clearer but
it's my experience my conclusion is my
experience is that children
often want to be heard have been
absolutely refused to be heard maybe not
in this kind of case maybe neglect and
abuse they always get hurt
but it doesn't sound like it and
definitely in divorce proceedings that
can get carried on forever
I've definitely met kids who were very
bright who would write letters they sent
letters to the judge but they were never
permitted to speak and they really
any questions for representative America
gay
seeing none thank you so much and I
would strongly suggest that folks both
who testified and of the committee
um share your thoughts with
representative hole it may be that this
becomes an early bill when the fiscal
note shows up so we don't have very long
to do it this concludes the hearing on
House Bill 535 and before you go
anywhere
um we have another bill to hear and let
me give you the background story to it
as you know the sununu youth center is
scheduled to close very soon
and by law
even in the design phase
so the Senate and the house have been
working very much behind the scenes as
quickly as we can to come up with a bill
and we have been given house bill 120.
um
what I am about to pass out to you is
House Bill 120 Amendment
0084 this language is identical to what
the Senate just passed
like a day or two ago
and so this is the current Senate
version what we will be asked to do down
the road fairly soon is to go along with
it thank you and that would happen to be
yeah
did he indicate when this was voted on
by the Senate
I would appreciate that because they're
supposed to be today the Senate is
taking a look at it in finance
so 120 FN the amended thing that I'm
about to give you may be a good document
to have and maybe what was just handed
to me is an amendment to this
does it sound complicated to anybody
yeah and confusing too what we're trying
to do is come to an agreement between
the house and the Senate through the
Committees through the financial
committees through the floor in voting
and out the door and signed within the
next few weeks I mean this is head
spinning
but that's the only way we can have
something legal to extend the life of
the sununu center and go forward to what
the department really needs so I'm going
to hand out these documents to you uh
House Bill 120
and then I'm going to hand out Senate
bill
Senate bill one Amendment these you're
going to have two different documents
no you're not you're going to have three
different documents
um msdaya
you've given me two different amendments
okay and you were
right there on the spot so you're going
to get free documents
and I just ask you to read them
make little smiley faces all over them
doodle
and it said somebody with his hand up
well I don't see anybody with his hand
up because I'm looking down but now once
you have all three documents in front of
you
the kindly gentleman with his hand up
instead of finances
so take the next 25 minutes or so and
read through
if
this is a new bill we're looking at then
I don't think we can are we not going to
have a public hearing on 120. we are
having a public hearing on the documents
before us this is a very unusual thing
yes I don't know how that can be if we
if we advertise it we'll have a public
hearing on 120 how we can jump into
another bill
we're going to do it without doing a
without posting another
hearing
amendments we can do but I don't know if
we can go to another bill particularly
one from another chamber of the Senate
without advertising we're going to hear
another bill well I take what you've
said under advisement and my ruling is
we will do this and the only way we
won't is by a challenge to the chair and
I would not recommend it do what of the
chair challenge of the ruling of the
we're going to discuss it this is going
to be a discussion 120 as you know it is
dead it is now followed by some other
yes
I mean these amendments haven't been
noticed so I'm wondering
if it's proper to uh
and it's properly even though these
amendments haven't been noted
right you can't
yeah
earlier
foreign
the hearing on House Bill
120 on the sununu Youth Services Center
and as we all know this is a work that's
going at warp speed
to try to accomplish some good work in a
very short period of time and both the
house and the Senate are working on this
and we hope to have something on the
governor's desk in four to six weeks
chair recognizes the chairman of
division three of Finance
the representative Jesse Edwards who is
going to present his bill and comment on
the amendment to it to make sure that
we're getting the latest updates
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair for the record I'm representative
Jess Edwards representing Rock cam
District 31. I live in Auburn but
represent three other towns as well
I have been tracking on the sununu issue
for quite a while I was appointed to a
special committee that was chaired by
Senator Gary Daniels to take a look at
options for
closing and replacing the sununu center
we did a lot of work on that published
final report I plus plus this this hit
division three after it passed the house
last year
and and so so we had a pretty good bill
that we took into committee a conference
and there was I I'd call it
miscommunication and the the the the the
the Fatal flaw in the miscommunication
is that the the bill to replace the
sununu center died in committee
conference and that was a really bad
thing because as it left our current law
to say that
um the sununu center must close on the
1st of March and so those of you with
the calendar clicking in your head you
know that's like five weeks from now
we have looked at alternatives on what
to do with these kids one of them just
to give you a worst case scenario one of
them is uh is uh being detained because
of uh allegation of murdering parents
so these can be pretty serious cases in
there and uh and and it isn't really
clear to me what happens on one March if
we don't pass something
um I I I don't think the commissioner
has good Alternatives and it may include
having to send some kids out of state
could cost a lot of money to do that
could could could be bad for their
therapy
so
um so what I'm really imploring this
committee to do is to understand that
we're on a very short window here and
that the people who disagreed in the
committee of conference last year are
either completely in sync with one
another now or are no longer serving so
we um So based on some of that I I wrote
HB 120
um simultaneously there was an sb1 done
by Senator Carson
um she had me work on an amendment for
her which is how closely I share that
just to let you know how closely we've
been working with one another she asked
me to to write an amendment that took
some of the best part of hers and the
best part of mine and build one and so
so although I'm introducing HP 120 today
I would I would draw your attention to
amendment to HP 120
to
2023-084 hotel and that I think that has
all been distributed before today
um and so this was an amendment
that is a replace all of HB 120 with
this document so HB 120 as we used to
say in the military is Obe it's been
overcome by events uh the the version uh
that that we're going after now in the
in the house is this amendment which
mirrors what the Senate passed 22-2 and
and one of the vital things we're doing
and have to do is we Fast Track This is
we have to keep this the the both houses
uh in sync with one another because if
we get out of sync and all the way down
to a comma they have to be identical to
help us facilitate rapid approval by
both houses and getting it to the
governor that that's really that's
really where we
achieve our success criteria is to get
the governor to sign this before the end
of February so that the one March
closure date is obviated
so
um so with that I I will begin to talk
about some of the more interesting
aspects of of the amendment
um and although much of this is
consistent with HB 120 I I just think
for the committee's purpose it would be
worth highlighting these and and I
should have mentioned that the committee
had a chair had invited division three
to to join us and could you raise your
hand if you're division three so I could
one
okay and and thank you thank you for
coming uh I I wanted division three to
be paying attention to the questions and
the and the introduction of this so that
um we're better prepared as a finance
committee to receive this product once
if it clears the house that we can we
can handle it more quickly so
um
the main issue in committee a conference
was the capacity some people wanted six
uh others wanted to plan the facility to
be able to operationally intend to
support 12 with a maximum ability to
handle 18 for sort of exigent reasons
I was talking to the director just a
little while ago and uh and and although
I had known that our census is has
ranged very in a very kind of consistent
manner around 12 to 14 he mentioned to
me that we hit 18 for the first time in
a couple of years so so to me I'm I
think it's validated that the 12 with
the potential to go up to 18 is is is a
good census data-driven Target now in
order to maximize the use of that space
we're asking that the the Interior Space
be designed so that there's some
flexibility so like for example if
you've got a combination of men and
women in there it's easier to divide the
you know the sleeping areas and the
common areas as appropriate if you have
members of competing gangs for example
it would be easier to segregate them to
increase safety so so the design is
going to have to create or be capable of
being somewhat flexible
now the location of where this thing
goes is a topic of a lot of rumor and
concern
three places have been named I'll let
the director talk about that but I just
want to tell you that from the
legislation's perspective we presume
that a location has not yet been picked
there are there are some good ideas on
where it may go but but officially and
technically no place has been picked yet
um so but because there are Community
concerns if you drop down to line 23
you'll note that this amendment says
that we will Implement any reasonable
requests by the communities to ensure
safe operation of the facility that is
future work that is work to be done
after you know we get deeper into the
site selection mode it's it's premature
to have done that at this point another
key point and I know this is really
important to The Advocates is is covered
at line 25 and 26 at the end of 20 line
25 it says the facility shall not be
administered by any non-governmental
entity what does that mean there there
was there has been discussion because
it's important to discuss all
Alternatives there has been discussion
about well should we consider
Contracting the entire operation out to
uh a for-profit entity that runs these
kinds of things and categorically every
conclusion has been no we do not want to
do that we will not do that and so so
what what 25 is meant to say is given
that it shall not be an administered by
any non-governmental entity it goes on
to say it shall be administered by the
Department of Health and Human Services
now keep in mind that the location is
being considered are on State Property
it's going to be built with State money
it's going to be in law administered by
the Department of Health and Human
Services and so for those who may be
concerned about the ownership or control
I I believe it's pretty clear that the
legislative intent is that this is uh
the state the state is accountable and
is responsible for making sure that all
operations are are done properly now
we'll see later but it's it's it's good
to mention now that
um
one of the drivers for wanting to close
the current's new new center
is because there has been frustration
over building for maybe 10 years that
the sununu center is pretty expensive on
a on an annual basis we spent about 13
million dollars a year you can do the
quick math if you've got census of 12 to
14 what that works out to be now it's
not the same 12 to 14 year round it's
there's there's movement in and out of
the facility but the the daily average
census tends to stay between 12 and 14.
13 million dollars a year that's quite a
lot so we think we can do
a a more efficient job in a facility
built and designed to create a
therapeutic environment when we first
built the 144 person facility that we're
currently in
144. what we built that for was more of
a juvenile incarceration Center the
model was very much about jail and and
imprisonment and what this legislation
does is it says it's it's going to be
the policy of the state to to worry
about the therapeutic treatment of these
kids and the you know basically the
restoration of them back to civil
Behavior
um if you go to the next page page two
very first line it's mentioned that once
we we open the new facility it'll be
called the YDC and not the sununu Youth
Development Center I've gotten feedback
by interested parties that they don't
like YDC and and rather than introduce a
little bit of chaos between keeping the
Senate and the house in sync what I've
what I've asked is for these things that
are rarely not relevant to pushing out
the the deadline and getting them
started on on architectural design let's
let's let's keep that separate so that
we can pass a bill in January of 2024 or
at least begin to the naming of the
facility is not on the critical path I
don't think and I I hope you would agree
with that as soon as the new center is
open on line seven it basically says
we're going to close the old system for
detention or admissions
um starting on line 10 it talks about
some facility design issues uh Alpha
through
India down from lines 10 to 26. I think
the first bullet is critical that we
what we're trying to do is complement a
therapeutic and trauma-informed care of
the children there to try to make it a
home-like interior and exterior to the
maximum extent practical now the
um that this also has to be done to make
sure that physical security is is
clearly in place and that these kids are
are detained in a controlled environment
where they cannot leave the premises
without proper authorization and escort
and the like so
um so so one of the major transition
points that you don't really see in this
bill
is that SB 14 back in 2019 which has
since become law established an acronym
cat and I think that's a comprehensive
assessment
therapy plan
treatment plan
um and so so the cat is something that
is an assessment of uh of somebody who
contacts the behavioral health system
and needs some some treatment plans and
so some portion of the the kids that end
up at the new YDC are going to have
these initial assessments and so so
we'll be able to hit the ground running
in theory
that with the continuity of care for
what what these youth need
that's different than if you had walked
in a a year ago to see what happened all
the initial assessment and stuff took
place on day one and it wasn't until
later that it was clear what kind of a
treatment plan was appropriate
and there was not a connection to the
community and so
um so I think one of the things that we
have going in our favor and this
redesign is that it's anticipated the
integration with the system of care tied
together by this cat and so that when
they get to the new YDC we're going to
be working on a therapeutic and
trauma-informed Care basis so so so so
so that's uh so that's good and and
later if you jump down the line 28
it'll it says operations May utilize
virtual and shared services so what the
hope is there and what the
communications have been is that
telemedicine can be used to link the the
youth that are at the YDC back with
their Community providers so that
there's more continuity and and that
should result in a better outcome
um so the but but the telemedicine is
not the only thing that can be delivered
with a remote or virtual Services as
we've learned the last couple of years
you know educational augmentation may be
a possibility
nice interaction with their family who
may not be able to travel to the center
but can still engage with them using you
know good high-end
equipment
so so emphasizing the virtual
and now on the shared side if we can
co-locate this facility with another
facility that is operating under
essentially the same model
that opens up the possibility of sharing
services like one of the most scarce
things we have in this state are trained
Manpower and so so by having a
co-location with a similar facility it's
hoped that any Manpower shortages might
be able to be compensated for by having
better sharing Arrangements but but the
care model isn't the only part that can
be shared you can share very fundamental
things like laundry services
warehouse and Logistics Services
you can share some security services so
so by emphasizing that the plan should
include virtual and shared services what
we're trying to do particularly with the
capacity reduction of an operational
size of 12 is we're trying to
dramatically shift that cost basis from
13 million dollars a year to a much
lower number and I'm not prepared to
give you an estimate but I I've got to
imagine it's it'll be on the order of a
third of what it is now the director may
have a better wag than me but a lot of
this analysis hasn't been done but it's
just got to be less expensive
so
um
for the community that receives this I
think line H is important line h on line
where it says necessary elements to be
architecturally secure and equipped with
video surveillance in compliance with
that RSA statute what that RSA statute
is is something that the legislature
passed last year and was signed into law
which says that their their shell was
essentially it says there shall be no
blind spots so wherever there's a common
area
it's it's capable of having the Acuity
to pick up individuals to know who's who
and to be able to monitor behavior in
common areas now of course the privacy
concerns are also built into this you
don't want to have you know bathrooms in
the wrong place or excuse me cameras in
the wrong place in the bathroom or in
their bedrooms for example but but I'm
going to leave leave that to the
engineers who are going to look at that
lawn apply some real world expertise to
giving us something we need that law
also says that we are going to Archive
these videos for years until the data
retention period expires and that the
equipment must maintain a 98 uptime or
better that was done at the request of
the AG himself who who has taken a look
at our video evidence in cases in the
last few years and realizes that our
uptime isn't what it really needs to be
so
um
we start into line 27 and 28 where it
talks about staff qualifications I I
think everyone in the community feels
good that we're looking to primarily
bring in therapeutic staff uh in here
we're going to make sure that they are
trained to also protect themselves and
others in a group we're going to make
sure that they're trained in
de-escalation techniques so so that we
can keep a safe environment internally
for every individual and every employee
and then also reduce the need for
external law enforcement to get involved
and reduce the anxiety the community
that these people may leave the premises
and become a threat to Public Safety so
so that's going to be looked at
um there has been some discussion that
this bill this version of this amendment
doesn't go far enough that we ought to
get a commission together composed of uh
some reps some Senators some local
people uh to to Really build out a plan
that you know dives into the procedures
and practices that would be followed so
so you don't see it in this version but
I could anticipate that in uh that by
the time this Fleet gets ready for the
house floor the last time it will have
Provisions for a commission to look at
the security issues
um
you'll notice on page three
on line three and four it talks about
the wrap around support upon admission
to plan for discharge so the whole
system is being again to make the point
this is being built on a therapeutic
model where the the juveniles coming in
should more than likely have some sort
of contact with the behavioral health
specialist and having this cat form
come in to keeping them engaged with
their providers during their stay to
when they get discharged have a graceful
transition of the discharge so so we're
talk we're we're imagining an entire
wraparound support system with the hope
that this is going to
improve the behavioral health aspects of
each individual and certainly address
some concerns about recidivism
and I practice that word Hall last night
I think I got it right
uh recidivism okay so further on page
three
um
we have
a paragraph here
that
um is is is pretty good about telling
the department what they need to do to
give us quarterly reports
um in in this in this version it says
that those quarterly reports would go to
the Joint legislative oversight
committee and also to the office of the
child advocate
um and and then there was an aha moment
where it should obviously also go to the
fiscal committee so I can imagine that
by the time this this gets ready to go
to the house floor for the final time
we're gonna we're gonna see
um
the fiscal committee mentioned as well
we're also going to make sure that any
money that we give them for this purpose
can't be transferred into any other
purpose that's not clear in this you
um I think of Interest maybe
on page four
um line 13 on down essentially what
we're trying to do to the between
13 and 22 is is uh to talk about
potential disposal now when when we
vacate the sununu center it's going to
turn over to be under the control of the
Department of administrative Services
the administrative services department
is going to start looking for the best
alternative uses they may get a head
start on it but officially that clock
doesn't start until they become
accountable and and what this
legislation does is it encourages a
prioritization of having that key
property if you've never been to the
sununu center it's on some of the most
important valuable property I think in
the state due to its proximity to
commercial
life and routes of access
and so so we're encouraging that they
look at the next use to improve the tax
and business rules of the City in the
state
there's an appropriation of 15 million
dollars to begin all of this analysis
we direct that the governor shall look
at some discretionary funds like in the
American Rescue plan act to see if they
can be allocated to put a dent in that
15 million dollars to reduce the burden
so so that's kind of a walk through uh
the amendment to HB 120
0084 hotel with a couple of of of rubs
that um probably need to be fixed uh and
an amendment to the amendment but I'm
I'm not here to to advocate for those
yet because I don't have a house
amendment to share with you at this
point just concerns that are on the
radar
so you know in summary I really need you
we need you the kids need you a
community needs you we got to get this
passed so that we don't end up with a
forced closure on one March so and it's
important that anything that we disagree
with on this we look to really align
closely with the Senate so that we can
get this bill passed expeditiously and I
swear I'll keep a list of things that
you think are issues so that we can
introduce it in a new bill January of 24
if needed so so with that I'm I'm
willing to take questions Mr chair
thank you representative you have done a
lot of work on this and you have done
Henry Kissinger level shuttle diplomacy
with the Senate how's that huh
um and I don't have his accent
um we will
keep a slot open on Tuesday afternoons
in this committee
so that if you have something to bring
to us especially in light of what the
Senate is passing will be able to be
ready right away to exec what comes to
us yes yes sir I appreciate that and
just to give you a foreshadow a little
bit I think the amendment that I have is
going to be amended one more time it's
going to be very much like this with the
points that I just verbally mentioned so
that there's still just one Amendment
overall but it'll really be the one that
I advocate for us to pass will that as
much as possible
mimic what the Senate is doing and the
Amendments that they've been working on
down to the comma so there will be no
um okay I've never fast tracked a bill
neither have I I don't mind making it up
too I don't know how that works I I sort
of feel like I'm uh running a relay race
and I'm just running as fast as I can
grabbing the Baton and getting ready to
hand it to the next one I have no idea
how this race ends
that's why we get the big bucks yeah
any questions for representative Edwards
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
in reading the amendment in the Bill
um I didn't see anywhere that the state
would Implement a system
that any surrounding communities
wherever the facility is is placed
um their support please fire whatever
would be reimbursed at all is that in
the bill am I missing it
it's in the amendment that you've not
seen yet it's it's it's absolutely
agreed that uh the amendment I just
introduced to you is is missing a key
component
oh okay so uh so uh thank you and I'll
I'll integrate your um your correction
and your teaching point but um but there
there there will be a commission that
will work with
um like the municipal governing board
local law enforcement the sheriff's
Association the child advocate the
commissioner Department of Safety and uh
it's it's it's it's it's my belief in in
Mr ribson points out that on lines 22 to
I think 25 or so
um it says that the department shall to
the extent practical uh Implement any
reasonable requests by the communities I
I did highlight that in my uh
introduction to ensure safe operations
Implement a payment okay there you go
that's the money line you're looking for
line 24. uh Implement a payment in lieu
of taxes arrangement to prevent the
shifting across the local taxpayer years
and to ensure the cooperation of the
prospective community so that so that's
our strategic Direction the commission
is going to be the required vehicle to
get us there representative I might
suggest in terms of that that you look
at the changing of the word Community to
communities just for the sake of
argument let's suppose this is cited in
Hampstead we already know with the use
of Hampstead Hospital there's memoranda
of understanding between the state and
the town and so on and one would assume
the same would happen no matter where
this facility is cited but should this
be cited in Hampstead there would need
to be an arrangement to your point
representative for Mutual aid for from
police and fire for towns a budding
Hampstead so I might suggest that that
be changed from Community to communities
so you know what they say great minds
think alike I I didn't consider that at
all but Senator Abbas did and and so
somewhere he's mentioned that we should
be talking about uh and and in one of
these versions We had the phrase
um adjacent or contiguous communities
whichever you can spell is fine with me
and and I you know with uh Mr Liam uh
helping I can probably spell them all
but
um but the uh
but I have to go back through here I'm
juggling like four different documents
and I don't I don't know where it is
that's a that's a good point
representative McMahon but thank you for
your work on this
um by the way as well uh relative to
your comments earlier of the previous
conference committee that begat no
decision does do the Amendments and the
ones come and meet the challenges that
were expressed during that conference
committee
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna do what may
sound like some marketing here
the the committee of conference got into
the crunch time and there were some
opportunities to improve it but because
the clock was running a lot of the
improvements didn't really make it in
the committee conference failed around
the capacity issue primarily that was
that was the big elephant that that
crushed the boat but
um but what we have done
is Senator Carson she came up with some
improvements to the committee a
conference I had come up with some
improvements the community econ or
committee a conference these things got
integrated and the Senate passed their
Amendment 22 to 2 to take the committee
conference as the Baseline and make it
better
so so I I would use the term new and
improved
I just want to follow on the 22-2 vote
is that what just happened this past
month
um I think it was just last week I'm
losing track of time but
um but this
Edward's Amendment uh
zero zero eight four is exactly what
passed 22-2 got it all right thank you
yes sir however it is fair to say that
the Senate has made two amendments today
yes some finance and that will work its
way into what you may present to us next
week right I have one more Amendment to
the amendment
wonderful representative long
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for your due diligence I
I know the headache that this has
created and I you did a great job
um my my only concern is you had
I have to see it
okay first page 25 and 26. right yes sir
I
I'm unfamiliar with administered I'd
like to see operated owned and operated
and administered by DHHS I I you know
can can can I tell you that that would
be a great thing to put into like a
January 24 bill I I and and the reason I
think I'm okay with this is that our
legislative intent is that this is going
to be on State Property built with State
money administered by the department
with the Department encouraged to look
for sharing and virtual Services I I
don't I don't think there's any doubt
that the intent is
um to to to go ahead and have the
control exercised by the department and
I I think that's what your concern is
does the word administrated versus
operated or the use of them both uh
connote that control better I you know
I'm not an English major so so I in the
in the discussions we agreed that
administered was sort of a more
enveloping term than operated that
operated feels more like a day-to-day
operations a more you know you know more
employees fewer shared services for
fewer shared contracts so so so we we
chose administered uh intentionally
now
I I'm reluctant to take on changes that
the Senate isn't in sync with for fear
that if it's not comma for period for
word uh we have a problem with getting
this passed fast and so what I would
have what I'd like to ask you Mr Vice
chair is the addition of the word and
operated that term
is that
significant enough to you to wear
it has to be there before you can
support this bill can it wait until sort
of a cleanup Bill January of 24.
find the answer thank you
I mean as far as supporting this I I get
it that this is an emergency and it
needs to be done
uh however I would prefer to know that
it'll be operated by DHHS could you help
me understand the word operated does
that mean a hundred percent
oh okay I cannot all right I was hoping
to build something with you that would
stand the test of time but uh but but my
eye and work of mine says operated means
operated
administered I don't know where that
gray is yeah so I would prefer I
will I vote for this I
I still have small yeah testimony I need
to hear yeah right right
um however I
I would be comfortable with operated
that tells me that it's going to be
operated by does the word operator do
you mean that there can't be contracting
of subordinate parts of the operation to
private entities oh they can be they can
be yeah okay so yeah so conceptually we
agree it's just it's just getting the
words right right uh you know like the
facility shall not be administered by an
non-governmental entity yeah that's what
so I mean does that mean that a barber I
can't hire a barber to come in and cut
people's hair yeah so so I'll tell you
what I'll I'll
because we have such a long history and
I I trust your judgment I I will try to
find a spot to work that in with the
Senate and then the chairman has said he
prefers communities plural instead of
communities well that's what my friends
in Atkinson
um
you're welcome okay just keep in mind
thank you representative all right
appreciate it yeah I'll I'll I will
endeavor
and check me when I come back with the
amendment to the amendment any further
questions for the representative however
abstruse they may be
you were selected here for a reason sir
Mr chairman
over here
thank you representative Edwards
um
I have a series of things to do I'm
wondering about because I haven't been
here for a little while I was here when
we created the synonym Center I went to
the inauguration office we were looking
for someone to blame
well I I and I'm glad you said that
because I don't know what's wrong it was
state of the art building we even named
a portion of it after Lionel Johnson who
totally totally a joke sorry oh Dad
okay
um so I'm I'm gonna watch what's so bad
about it except 13 million dollars to
run it yeah I thought it was a beautiful
building it's it's more than that uh oh
are you have you answered it well asked
the question so at some point I'd like
you to know what the differential and
cost is going to be I didn't see that
here you said 13 million dollars so
therefore we need to do something then
that's the only thing I've heard so far
that says we got to get into a different
building because this one costs too much
to operate which I expect most of the
operational costs were uh uh people
people that run the place because the
facility we got most of the money from
the federal government that's why it's
called the sununusa right because sununu
was able to procure the funds uh forest
for that building and I I wonder if that
uh building could be used for uh mental
health or uh homeless problems that we
have
um I guess we don't need as much we used
to use the king cottages
uh prior to the student who said and the
Court ruled that we had to do something
different and that's why we went into
the shinuno center
um
and a lot of people thought that that
wasn't going to be big enough
uh but apparently it's too big now
so
um
and I if this
emergency so far all I can understand is
because we have a date to sell it
and that if it's just a date to get rid
of it we can that's an easy Bill to push
that through without worrying about
getting the new one bill we can come
back and do that
so if any of that you can help me with
to understand I I'd say it's the
opposite the you know the problem isn't
disposing of the building this this this
bill doesn't say how it will uh how it
will be used in the future just simply
says we'll turn it over to das and
they'll figure it out once we're done
with it but we're not done with it until
we can move the kids into an appropriate
setting and so so you know just to put
it in a you know the financial terms you
got to look at it from an efficiency and
an Effectiveness perspective we're
looking to gain efficiency by
consolidating the amount of space that
needs to be controlled and supervised
and cleaned and heated and all of that
and and and get an appropriate size
staff a staff built for 12 instead of a
much larger number so we're trying to
gain efficiency but but that that takes
our eye off the other ball and the other
ball is the effectiveness what we've
determined is that sort of the the hard
wall concrete cinder block prison feel
of the sununu center is not appropriate
to the kind of
therapy-centric care that we want to
provide to these kids so so the the the
environmental setting will become much
more home-like and I think I pointed out
that that particular paragraph where we
talked about that
it's uh on page two
line 12 and it just kind of goes a
physical design including a home-like
interior and exterior to the maximum
extent practical what we're building is
is more like a treatment center and less
like a prison and that and and that's
what sununu is now it's a facility
appropriate to prison it's a prison that
can hold up to 144. I I don't know how
we ever thought we would keep 144 kids
in there you know I I wasn't here then
um but as I've seen the census provided
by the department
it wasn't all that long ago eight years
maybe where we were having a census like
80 or something and and that that has
trailed off in the last two three years
to where the range of of 12 to 14 seems
to be the steady state so
um
so we're building a facility more
suitable we're building a facility where
we can co-locate it with a similar
facility to leverage capabilities uh
gain some efficiency and some expertise
and and Child Development Behavioral
Health so
um the what I what I meant to
communicate when I talked about the 13
million dollar a year Bill Bill
it cost uh is that over the years more
senior members of the finance committee
than I am and this is only my second
grew very frustrated that they weren't
getting from the Department what they
thought they needed in terms of a cost
reduction plan and and so
there was this pent-up
urgency to basically force the issue
to be fair if you went over to the
department and you asked them they go
well legislature never told us to do
that or where's the bill where's the
where's the you know HP to that made us
go do that and and so I I don't know I
wasn't here I it sounds in retrospect
like you know entities talking past each
other and and now the department the two
houses of the legislature I haven't
mentioned the governor's office they're
they're all I think in sync on what the
replacement
ought to look like and we can't close
what we have until we can replace what
we have and so this bill is about the
replacement so it's a long answer is it
is it on point
do you wish a follow-up representative
Bickford no not this time thank you okay
anyone else
representative Levesque
I don't know if
the uh Mr chairman thank you for taking
my question I don't know if you can
answer this or is someone else that's
going to speak
um
when discussing the uh de-escalation
techniques uh what exactly would those
entail
uh because as we know like dealing with
children it's hard to
cross that line between uh making sure
that they are safe for themselves and
when I it's like of abuse almost and
what those uh de-escalate student
techniques look like and what they are I
don't know if you could answer that or
someone else can so okay so I'll do I'll
give you the big picture and then the
department can provide uh detail but you
know there's sort of in engineering
there's this top-down structured
approach to to building things and and
and we're kind of at a higher level we
know that we have to get to the depth in
order to answer your question and so
what we've done at this higher level
which is in this bill is to to include
de-escalation as a technique and and we
kind of feel ourselves to be a bit
enlightened because the whole concept of
de-escalation in law enforcement I think
is is just more or less of a relatively
current topic now now what the details
of that are there's going to be an
opportunity long before the new facility
is reopened to to to work that out
so I think we also said in here that to
the extent that they can begin this new
operational model of therapeutic help
that they can begin implementing it so I
so that T it's the answer to your
question is still TBD but it's obviously
going to be on our critical path to
opening
representative Grossman
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for coming before us and
um my question is related also to those
therapeutic
has so have the therapeutic changes
happened I know we're talking about the
structure of the build you know and but
at the current sununu Center the
movement from incarceration towards
community-based therapeutic changes have
those begun
happening already at the sununu center
or are these changes these movements
happening once we get a new facility
excellent question excellent question I
I miss ribson will have the the details
of the exact status of the
implementation but I but I do understand
I think that the context where we're at
the the legislature was obligated to get
this bill to the governor for passage
back in June we didn't do that so if
you're an employee at the sununu center
what we just did was we unleashed a
tremendous amount of uncertainty and one
of the things you may have tracked is
that they've had both attrition problems
and and recruiting problems and to the
point to where they've had some violence
erupt inside because they're just not
adequately staffed and so there's a
saying this is something like it's it's
hard to remember you went into during
the swamp when you're wrestling with
alligators and so I I think that the the
declining staff has it has made it more
challenging for them to begin
implementing the therapeutic model
changes but to the extent that they have
I'd give them Kudos because it's you
know it's tough to do it in the face of
massive
attrition
further questions for the representative
seeing none thank you and we'll see you
again next week all right thank you so
much for the time the chair recognizes
Cassandra Sanchez Office of the child
advocate she wants to speak for between
two and five minutes in support of the
good afternoon Mr chair and thank you
for your time
I am here in support of the bill and I
may be able to answer some prior
questions that were asked as well about
the treatment model the office of the
child advocate has been very vocal in
pushing for a treatment Approach at the
facility and moving to a therapeutic
home-like facility away from as
representative Edwards mentioned away
from the brick walls the heavy metal
doors to a facility that will feel more
like a treatment center
and so in this bill we have been very
supportive of all of the aspects that
include those treatment modalities to be
used and especially the implementation
of them now at the current facility
I do spend quite some time at the
current facility I've met with the
children talked to them about their the
current therapeutic treatment as well as
the psychologist that oversees the
clinical
um therapeutic components that already
exist within the program
and currently at this time the children
are receiving one-on-one therapy they
have opportunities for family therapy as
well as group therapy the group therapy
was not consistently happening prior to
this current time frame because of the
staffing issues that were mentioned
by representative Edwards Pryor so there
was with this the crisis in the facility
in the unknown there was departure of
clinical staff and there was need for
hiring of clinical staff they now have
more adequate clinical staff and are
able to meet those needs by offering
more of that therapeutic component
I don't believe they are where we would
like to see them when this fully rolls
out and they're able to further
Implement that therapeutic approach but
they are on the way already with the
um what I do see for in speaking to the
de-escalation question that was asked in
my understanding
um of the science behind de-escalation
in in therapeutic settings for children
it is about using approaches where you
are talking to them in the moment it is
having the treatment plans in place that
identify coping skills for the child so
if they are in crisis it's offering them
their coping skills first getting down
on their level meeting them where
they're at and understanding what may be
triggering to them in that moment so
that that is not that approach isn't
utilized so if it is somebody coming too
close in contact with them it may be
taking a step back and showing them that
you're giving them the space that they
need and so that's what we see for
de-escalation techniques and other
therapeutic settings and we would like
to see that carry through at the
facility some of that has been
incorporated into the treatment plans
already but there is a training
component that would come with this bill
that would allow further training for
the Direct Care staff because right now
the clinical staff are on site but
they're not on the floor with the kids
at all times and so they the training
needs to happen with the staff that are
directly working with the children on
their units in the the lunchrooms when
they're mixing when they're socializing
and also in the education setting so
really carrying that through and that
can happen through enhanced training
they're doing some of those trauma
trainings now but with the roll out and
the Prime Focus shifting from detention
center to treatment center that will be
able to enhance
I will point out one aspect of of this
amendment which I did vocalize to the
Senate as well
um one area of concern otherwise I
support this amendment in full the area
of concern is in speaking to the
utilization of virtual and shared
services
and this is not saying that I don't
believe that that should be offered to
the children at the facility but I do
believe that it should be considered an
add-on to the services already in place
understanding the amount of work that
has gone into the face-to-face Clinical
Services that are happening now I would
not like to see the facility take a step
backwards and utilize virtual therapy or
virtual schooling for children with IEPs
if it's not going to truly meet their
needs so really taking a look at the
virtual component as an add-on to the
in-person services that will be
happening face to face with the children
I absolutely see that it can be an
enhancement by having a therapist in the
community who has followed the child
over time to have access to them while
they're in the facility and communicate
with their treatment team
but they should still have that because
they will not have the opportunity to
meet with that person face to face they
should still have the opportunity to
meet with a clinician on-site face to
face and have that treatment come
together as one and not two separate
um options for for therapeutic care for
I read that line to mean if the facility
were cited right next to another
facility doing similar work that could
share Food Service since they'll not
have to have two completely separate
ones and that if let's say Hampstead
Hospital has certain staff people gifted
in certain areas of mental health those
people could actually work at both
under that heading I would see that
shared services could be an advantage
and not a disadvantage
in that aspect yes I'm speaking more to
the virtual component not necessarily
the shared services thank you for that
clarification thank you representative
McMahon
Ms Sanchez uh this is specific to what
the chair just referred to as well
would wording saying operations shall
include utilization
of virtual shared and in-person services
I'm sorry can you point me to the the
line that was on uh page 2 line 26. oh
yes yep
and in in the interest of inclusion so
that the three disciplines can be
recognized based on need of the
individual
is is that do I understand that's what
you're recommending those suggesting
should be included
those three options or should one of
them be
I believe there's another location
where it touches on
um a virtual component and I believe
it's in the education area
um what page in line would that be
Shelby yes right there it notes virtual
education opportunity shall be leveraged
appropriately to help meet the
resident's needs so ensuring that this
would not allow this language would not
allow it to be
used instead of but as an option if it
is a good fit for that specific child
but not that if there's not access to an
educator that they will be able to
supplement by offering virtual only to
uh
uh well well the question was specific
to it including the three opportunities
and what is the best uh therapy to
utilize
would would then go to the the second uh
the second uh page there you were just
I mean should that not be included as a
as you know so the options there's the
three options are available
not restricted
you know it's I mean leverage can
Leverage is a matter of leveraging
multiple entities yes so yes it can be
utilized it's just I'm making note to
ensure that it could not be intended
instead of but that it joining in both
or in addition to what is already
offered on site then yes I am in
agreement with that opportunity being
available to the children so is there
any further language change versus what
was offered here by representative
Edwards
I have not offered any additional
specific language to that I did speak in
the Senate with asking as they're
considering to look at amendments to
have that language say in addition to
um but further than that I have not had
further conversation with representative
Edwards as to Amendment language
my guess would be that this would be
unpacked by the department as it
implements it and we can trust that they
know how to do it
as opposed to making sure it's written
right in the bill
that wasn't a question but it could have
been
anybody else uh Mr chairman you're on a
roll go I am do you trust what the chair
uh
so respectfully I do I do trust that
that
they can do their duty but I would like
to be cautious knowing that there have
been times where staffing has been an
issue and have seen that the virtual
option had been the only option for
children so that is why I brought that
forward because I did speak with
children over the summer months where
the Staffing was not in place and there
was virtual therapy offered to them and
many children at that time voiced that
it was not enough to meet their needs
and that they needed further therapeutic
care in the facility just one closings
comment Mr chairman my attempted human
notwithstanding the uh point is well
taken here and then our past experience
with my past experience working with the
chair and other committees is to
anticipate what not what's happening
what what may happen and what does
happen and you'll be working them with
the Senate and with represent the
representative to have a language that
provides that the structure for these
in blackletta law
and on page 3 line 29 it indicates the
Department of Health and Human Services
shall submit quarterly progress reports
to the Joint legislative committee on
I'll make sure
thank you you're welcome
anyone else we take do we take minutes
thank you Mr chairman
um and thank you Miss uh Sanchez for
taking my question
um on
page three
um
number five which uh Roman numeral five
which is line 26. it says the Department
of Health and Human Services shell began
to implement the programming changes and
subparagraphs for a through K without
regard to whether children are at the
syfc or the new facility as soon as a
reasonably practical
um and that I have to say is my favorite
line in this entire Bell
um but I'm curious as to whether or not
um it is practical to implement some of
these programming changes in the current
environment are there things in here
that simply cannot happen until a new
facility is built because I know that
we're in the middle of a big renovation
in Nashua and I know how long these
things take
um so you know are there things that we
need to be concerned about that the kids
need now that they may not be able to
get yet
I do believe that it is practicable to
roll this out now for the children in
the facility a lot of it as I had
mentioned comes down to training of the
staff and the current
um so changing some of the current
policy that aligns with the way in which
the facility operates which can be done
in the current facility of course with
the therapeutic full facility built
therapeutically
it will offer more opportunities for
children to
um de-escalate potentially on their own
or
um and also we understand the the impact
of being in a facility that appears like
a Detention Facility like they are in
now which can be further traumatizing
for the children so by pulling that
aspect away that will help with the
treatment progress but that will not
derail the ability to start that
therapeutic process now and start making
some of those changes to the policies
and and the practices that occur in the
facility okay thank you
representative Bickford
thank you Mr chairman
we've heard this therapeutic word for
years in fact when we started the sununu
center we heard it's going to be
therapeutic so don't worry about
anything and here we are
um
now you commented that
uh you didn't like the idea of the
bricks and mortar and Buzz on it how do
you envision Envision this to
be constructed
I envisioned the facility to look more
of what we see when we would visit a
residential facility in the state where
they do there's it's a smaller building
some of them may even be a house and
they're able to outfit the inside with
the necessary video cameras But the
rooms won't don't necessarily have those
heavy doors that that lock in the same
way and moving through the the building
also would not necessarily have those
though it would be a locked facility
unlike the residential facilities but it
wouldn't have those locks in in between
as they're entering or moving about the
facility and it would have a space where
children can join and mix together that
would feel more like your living room at
home than being in what feels like an
office space right now
okay so that's kind of follow-up
follow-up thank you yes
that's kind of where we came from from a
king cottages
where they had Cottages or large
Cottages actually
so we're going full circle
so do you happen to know
what the cost will be to run this
facility
the new facility
I do not have the operating costs I will
defer to DHHS for that oh okay thank you
thank you
I see no hands up
sure recognizes Karen Rosenberg
disability rights Center of New
Hampshire and up here she writes she
supports the bill but requests
um good afternoon I'm Karen Rosenberg
I'm the policy director at the
disability rights Center of New
Hampshire I'm here to testify on behalf
of the disability rights Center as well
as the juvenile rights policy Group
which is a coalition of several advocacy
organizations who advocate for children
including Waypoint New Hampshire legal
assistance the ACLU New Hampshire and
new futures
so first of all yes this has to happen
and you all and representative Edwards
and Folks at the Senate have done a
tremendous amount of work really rapidly
to advance what will hopefully be a bill
that will cross the finish line this
time that will keep Kids Safe that will
result in a therapeutic treatment model
for children who need to be detained or
committed to a secure facility for a
brief period of time both for their
treatment needs as well as for Community
safety and you're well on your way to
doing that
so in part my request is that you
um adopt what's in representative
Edwards proposed amendment which mirrors
the Senate bill with one tweak
um The Tweak is that we want to make
sure that this facility is owned and
operated by the department and I I think
that it's really the intent of the
Senate and hopefully the house that that
be the case but
being an attorney you know who went
through that whole you know law school
lives her entire life a you know worst
case scenario
um
we would encourage you to make sure that
it's absolutely clear I mean this is
important because with State ownership
and operation we have transparency right
we have unconditional oversight we have
the applicability of our state right to
know law we know with ownership that if
there is a contract and the contract
goes south that we will have a facility
we're not just throwing 15 million
dollars at some other entity
um you know who we're Contracting with
so I understand that that's the intent
um but like I said in that worst case
scenario game that you know some of us
who went to law school can't get our
heads out of it would be really clear to
tighten up that language
similarly with operate versus
administrate the buck needs to stop with
the state the state needs to be overall
responsible for the operations to
maintain this safety of the children
there to make sure that this facility
that
we all are going to create here is
actually going to do what it says it's
going to do in this bill right we want
those kids to be safe we want to make
sure that the office of the child
advocate has appropriate access to this
facility and the children that they're
actually getting the therapeutic
services that they need and that and and
we can hold the state accountable to
that so
this is why the language is really
important and it actually is not
anything new I mean when you think about
it the state already owns and operates
New Hampshire hospital this is not to
preclude Contracting Services when
appropriate right that's not the
intention here we're not saying like
state has to you know basically do every
single thing ever all the minutiaev of
actually running the facility but as we
do with like New Hampshire hospital the
state owns that facility they contract
with Dartmouth Hitchcock Medical Center
for Medical Services and Psychiatric
Services so this has been done before
similarly with Hampstead Hospital the
arrangement is that the state owns it
and operates it and I looked up recently
the contract that we have that the
request that the department filed with
on the executive Council for permission
to contract with an entity that provides
services for Hampstead and it says the
department will be the owner and
operator responsible for all functions
of this Hospital this includes
developing overall Strategic Mission of
Hampstead ensuring quality services are
provided by the contractor in compliance
with all contractual requirements as
well as all federal and state laws and
regulations I mean that's the kind of
thing the assurance that we're looking
for here and it could be accomplished
with a really simple tweak which is just
changing the word along the lines of
what representative long was saying he's
the tweaker so um and to make it clear
that this facility would be owned
operated and administered by the
department
um but allowing for them I think the
language that's already in the um
Edwards Amendment
um so if you look at page one lines
let's see
26 and like I guess it goes from lines
25 to 27.
um if you replace the sentence starting
with the fiscal delete shall not be
administered by you know and then it
continues to another sentence the
facility shall be administered by the
Department of Health and Human Services
you could replace those two sentences
with something like
um that the facility shall be owned and
operated by the Department of Health and
Human Services with support and shared
service contracts as appropriate I think
that would address this concept that yes
it is appropriate at times to Contract
Services I believe that this new center
currently contracts Services Clinical
Services and I think maybe even some
Educational Services when appropriate so
um that's that's my pitch would you
believe on my bucket list just crossed
out is wanting to see a lawyer and an
iron worker come to Unity
wow yeah I'm glad I could help you out
lawyers and iron workers we're all
playing the worst case scenario game
the curse
I'm happy to entertain anything I don't
know how anybody could top that but if
you have a question I bet the uh the
lawyer
what the guy
no I'm saying none thank you so much
thank you
foreign
recognizes another lawyer
and and a New Jersey
born and raised and educated
Eastern New Jersey
answer that question too
he is a lawyer and not but a good guy
thank you good afternoon everybody Joe
ripsom director dcof in fact I I'm sorry
to to correct you but I'm actually no
longer a lawyer when I moved to New
Hampshire and took this job I let my
license in New Jersey expire because I
wasn't going to be practicing law any
longer and there wasn't reciprocity and
I didn't feel like taking the bar again
so it's not like ordination then no okay
no
um so it's on suspense my license is on
suspended status in New Jersey and at
some point I'm going to have to
reconcile that before it before it
absolutely is you know but I'll cross
that bridge some other day so we are
here in support of of the Bill of the
amendment
um I originally was thinking I'd do a
line by line but you guys have had that
opportunity already so I don't want to
exhaust
um you know everybody's time any more
than necessary
um you know a couple just big key
components right the first section of
the bill really just talks about the
facility besides the facility to go cope
with the facility there's a little bit
of data that I wanted to share which was
in the PowerPoint that I shared a couple
weeks ago but we didn't make it that far
so I'm going to hand this document out
thank you
so
this is just data being passed around
showing the census of sysc
it is the actual daily census which is
why you see it jumping around so much
from July 1 2016 through January 1 2023
and you do see the actual census back in
2016 and 17 sometimes peaking into that
mid 70s level
and then you see kind of this you know
this kind of crash
um around like 2019 and 2020 where you
start hovering into this kind of 20s 30s
and then kind of staying within those
teens from that point that was around
the time that two different things
happened one the Advent of the
children's system of care
and two changes in law around who could
be detained and committed at sysc so
those two things kind of happened at the
same time around then and that's really
when the census of sysc dropped to what
it is that we see today which on average
is 12 but on any given day could be as
low as five and as of two days ago for
the first time in two years actually did
get up to 18 for two days before two
days ago the highest we had seen was 17
for for a few days but so the census can
get and it was as low as five in
November right so the census can move
pretty quickly pretty you know and
pretty you know dynamically between
those numbers but it hasn't exceeded
that number of 18 since early 2020 and
that's kind of what we're banking on the
um really next portion of this bill goes
into kind of what we're talking about in
terms of what we want the facility does
designed to look like and what we want
um you know the the facility itself
physically to have right both in terms
of the number of kids that it can serve
but also you know that we need
visibility for staff that's one way that
you're able to kind of
um be a little more efficient with your
Staffing patterns is ensuring visibility
one of the challenges of working within
144 bed facility that's spread out quite
far is you have poor visibility and
therefore you have to have sometimes
depending on how you're Staffing and
your youth are structured more people in
the building to spread out than you
would if you were in a space that you
have better visibility in kind of Staff
within a and youth within a closer space
talking about having you know just
things for medical physical Behavior
Health Care needs flexibility in space
so we're talking about 18 beds it's not
that we anticipate having 18 kids there
typically as I said we're typically
looking at an average of 12 but we often
have kids that need to be separated for
different reasons right so it could be
separated because you might have male
Youth female youth that you don't want
to have them sleeping in the same
quarters you may also have youth who
can't be sleeping in the same quarters
because they have court orders that say
that these youth have to be separated
because maybe they committed common
offenses or maybe they have
um
um you know maybe they're involved in
activities outside or inside the
facility that are dangerous to one
another sometimes we have kids that are
relatively aggressive and kind of pick
on other kids who are a little more less
you know or a little more vulnerable to
those types of situations so we have to
separate them so you need to have some
space to separate kids even if you're
not maximizing every single bed every
single night and I do anticipate that we
won't be maximizing every bit every
night but we still need to have that
space
um one of the things that we've been
talking about
um with potential Architects is the idea
too of being able to have some flexible
wall movement in order to move unit size
around right so for example you know
most nights we only have for the past
year we've only had one female in the
building at a time now they integrate
for programming but for sleeping they're
alone but if you have one female at a
time and you have say a five bed female
unit that that cuts off a lot of other
beds
um and if you end up with say 14 boys
one night you're you're in trouble
so
um we've been talking about how do you
you know with with potential Architects
about how do you mitigate and plan for
things like that and be able to make an
18-bit facility work for these purposes
um
uh key things in here around you know
educational space medical space for the
kids clinical space for the kids
um recreational space this is New
Hampshire we need indoor recreational
space because we can't always count on
being able to go outside with the kids
and we definitely need to keep these
young folks active if they're not active
you do see that play out in in behaviors
and other things like that
um the last piece of this the last kind
of critical piece of this in terms of
the facility itself is the next section
of the bill that talks more around the
programming of the facility kind of
moving more towards this trauma-informed
treatment clinically informed
programming and critically situating
sysc within the broader system of care
for children so historically one of the
big troubles with sysc and probably the
prior YDC has been that it's operated
kind of on an island separate and apart
from the rest of children's Behavioral
Health and frankly there wasn't even a
children's Behavioral Health as we spoke
about last time that I was here and I
think I think you all had the benefit of
a of a presentation this morning from
our colleagues in children's Behavioral
Health so some of the terms that
representative Edwards spoke about
hopefully were somewhat familiar from
that presentation this morning
but really situating this within that so
that the kids at syc have access to the
same exact assessments the the cat
assessments they have access to the same
Care Management entity so that if they
get detained at sysc they're then
getting the same Care Management entity
fast forward or Trek to work with them
on how to discharge and get them back to
the community and keeping them safe in
the community and doing all of that work
to really have them be part of that same
integrated system so that kids who end
up at sysc end up being part of that
broader Behavioral Health Care system to
keep them safe and out of a place like
sysc for the long term
um and a host of other important things
in here around kind of programming and
planning and things like that
um I'll just pause and like I said I
don't want to go too deep in too long
because you guys have had a lot of that
already and I I don't want to waste your
time and just take questions as you have
how long is this day generally
for
some of the kids that I know it it's
there's no but generally how long
yeah it varies um depending on the
circumstance so your typical detention
right so you have detained kids which
are kids who are pending some type of
adjudication right
um many detained kids could be there for
as short as a matter of days meaning
like you know they're picked up some
things some they've committed some type
of offense after a couple days a court
will decide you know what things have
cooled down we're gonna let you go home
and wait to have you know you'll go to
court
um and that'll get settled later other
times kids will stay in detained for a
few weeks while they're waiting for
their court date
um other times if a child is being
charged with a really serious offense
and potentially pending adult charges
and that's unusual we don't see that
happen too often in New Hampshire but
something like a murder charge those
young people will stay in detained
status potentially for years
right because those cases if they're
pending an adult charge can take
they'll go through a certification
process and a lot of those they'll be
waivers on a lot of those kind of time
frames and stuff as they're going
through all those processes so those
kids could stand there for a very very
long time and they're probably our
longest stairs by far so then the other
piece of it is instead of detained is
committed kids who have been adjudicated
and they've been sentenced and the way
the laws Now read in New Hampshire for
most offenses it's only a three-month
stay prior to parole
um so it's three months and they can
actually get out sooner than that if
they demonstrate that they're that
they're kind of stable and able to kind
of step down to a another type of
program or facility
um and and we have the authority to do
what's called an administrative release
at that point
um if not they go to a parole hearing at
three months and the parole board makes
a decision as to whether they're ready
to step down at that point or not and
for more serious offenses it's typically
a six month before parole so what you
typically see if you're a committed
population is more often a three-month
but sometimes a six month they're really
long stairs like I said to those those
really serious offenses pending adult
charges and they're pretty rare but they
any further questions
representative Bickford thank you Mr
chairman
what's it going to cost to run this
thing what's finance committee going to
get for our number sure so as part of
the committee that looked at the closure
of sysc about 18 months ago
we provided some estimates around the
operational cost of the current facility
versus what the estimate of what the
costs could be of operating a smaller
co-located facility and it was you know
Savings of around two to three million
dollars a year to do that
you said savings right yes
so if I may go on that would be
13 000 down to eleven thousand or not
thousand million Millions sysc budget I
know people like to save 13 million the
actual current syac budget was 10.4
million
why do I like to do that
because that's what it was the last
biennium not the current biennium okay
um
okay not when you when you gave me that
number does that include the bond
payments
I assume there's going to be Bond
payments the bill anticipates that the
construction costs will be funded
through arpa so there would not be Bond
Okay so
one more
there's not a lot of significant savings
going on here I think you know a few
million dollars a year over potential
decades
is I I you know I think that's
significant but
thank you you could get a new parking
garage for the legislature
good idea
representative Raymond
thank you chairman um and uh thank you
director for coming and answering our
questions
um on the question of money uh the bill
says 15 million to build this facility
and
um I'm involved in building school
facilities right now and our budget is I
don't know 90 100 million dollars right
now and we're gonna bust it because we
can't get what we need now that's for a
significantly larger population but
you're going to need a lot of the same
uh high cost items like
um therapeutic facilities and
educational facilities which have
specific building codes and flex space
and interior gym facilities is 15
million dollars like was there a study
to come up with that number or did is
that like a hopeful number so that was
you know so DHHS did not come up with
that estimate that was an estimate that
was provided by department
administration our Department
administrative Services Public Works 18
months go yeah when the study committee
first came together right the study
committee the representative Edwards
referenced the recent fiscal note does
have a higher number attached to it that
being said
um I think there's there's a lot of
unknowns right so and there's some
things that would be different depending
on where facility is located for example
if we were to relocate if we were to
build this facility in Manchester at its
current site we would need to build a
commercial kitchen if we were to build
this facility next to an existing
facility where we could have the food
prepared there and brought over we
wouldn't need to build a commercial
kitchen right there's certain things
like that that are going to depend upon
where the facility is located that are
going to impact the cost of the facility
so there's a lot of unknowns that being
said construction costs and labor costs
have definitely gone off since the
original estimate was was put out so I
think there are yes your point is well
taken and at the same time there are
other variables that are that are
unknown thank you 18 months ago is
are you waving or do you have a question
you have a question okay representative
Grossman
thank you chairman
um
oh I just lost my thought
do you believe that even though
the cost savings may not be this
enormous you know three million
do you believe that this will be
beneficial not just in dollar amounts
but in emotional health behavioral
health of the population so that
the cost benefit we will reap rewards
from it yeah I think there's multiple
ways to think about it right I think one
right there's just what's the right
thing to do for kids right I think from
that from that perspective it's there's
not even an argument on the other side
to be made
um from the cost of perspective though I
think there are multiple things if you
want to just talk dollars and cents
um in terms of things like you know the
success rate of keeping kids from you
know recidivism and ending up in the
adult system and being able to actually
have productive adult lives
um you know a lot of research says that
these Correctional modalities of
treating kids are not effective
um so you know why not try try something
a little more better and a little more
effective and I uh you know so I think
you know from a cost perspective you
have that I think you also have like I
said the um the reality of a few million
dollars a year every year for a long
period of time is I think
meaningful and will you know exceed the
cost of the actual building of the new
facility in a number of years as well as
the value of the property whatever ends
up being done with that property which
won't be my decision but is something
thank you
and this concludes the hearing on House
Bill 120 for everyone's purpose we will
come back again three o'clock next
Tuesday
I have to build that into the calendar
so in case we have something
to vote on
we will be able to and perchance next
Tuesday we don't have anything new we'll